the chairman's script
before i before i gavel in
the uh
the
first bill first i'm going to
open the me open the hearing
opening the meeting and i'm going to re
have to read the chairman's script which
says
as chair of the house resources
recreation and development committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covet 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67
in the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2 12
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a uh this is a
uh
please note this is that well this is a
committee hearing
please note
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary
participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all neces all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 1991 a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271 3600
or email
hcs
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff
that are
are on the meeting assisting us brad
greenland
please note that all votes that are
taken during the meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
we'll start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state
that there is
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting this is required
under the right to know law
all right
i will ask the clerk
to please call the role
you have to speak as loud as you can
i don't know how well
how well is it
can you hear it
[Music]
yeah
representative harb
i am here in my office that i am alone
at the present time
representative crichton
here
harvey bolia here
representative healey yeah
representative mayville
here and alone in the room
you have to unmute yourself
or is you
uh representative smith is here and i am
in my office at home alone
representative spang
i'm here and i am alone
representative grassy
i'm here alone
representative gottling
at home and alone
representative cohen
i'm here and alone
representative
here
representative connors here
representative
here
[Music]
uh representative moran is here and
alone
thank you
and representative
oh that's it
oh and um i'm sorry chair
uh ren zulu
i'm here obviously
okay
all right
yeah
are we
is everyone here
yeah
so
everyone is here
[Music]
all right i'll open the meeting and
256 and the chair recognizes
uh the uh rep represent representative
rung
to uh
to introduce the bill
thank you very much chairman renzolo uh
for the record my name is rosalie wrong
i'm state representative for
hillsborough 21 which is in merrimack
can everyone hear me okay
all right
um two years ago governor sununu signed
into law hb 737 which established a
commission to study the health and
environmental impacts of pfas
contamination resulting from the
merometic operations of sangobain
performance plastics
the commission is represented by five
state representatives two state senators
officials from nhda des department of
environmental services the new hampshire
department of health and human services
the united states geological survey the
new hampshire medical society unh an
environmental scientist and residents
and local officials from the three
communities impacted by single-base
contamination bedford litchfield and
merrimack
the commission has been very successful
in gathering research and data
recommending actions and communicating
to stakeholders on this subject
i am currently serving as its chair
unfortunately londonderry has also been
shown to have groundwater contamination
from sinkhole veins operations
in our interim report issued in november
of 2020 the commission recommended
unanimously to introduce legislation to
add londonderry to the commission
membership
thus i am before you with this bill it
is vital as the commission moves forward
that londonderry have an equal voice
along with the three other communities
if possible i ask that you take action
on this bill as soon as you are able
since public information initiatives are
underway and londonderry needs to be
part of these
thank you in advance for your
consideration and i'm happy to address
thank you are there any uh any questions
uh
from the from the uh committee committee
members
uh is there any
uh
representative creighton is there anyone
is there anyone well is there anyone
from the
the
visual
okay
i can uh oh i i get asked if somebody if
there's any questions uh
is there any questions on the from the
zoom members
looks like looks like there are no
looks like there's no questions from the
witnesses excused
and i'll go to the
the
the other the attendees who have asked
to
who have asked to testify
uh
representative uh
is uh
do you want to see if she raise their
hand
one second okay one click away
okay
uh asian mckinney had her hand up and
i'm trying to get her on here get her on
that's you up
hey brad i i have no ability to turn
betsy's mic on here
her hand is up but i don't have the uh
can you repeat that representative
betsy's hands is up
but i do not have a prompt to allow her
to speak
okay um i can allow her to speak on my
all right i just enabled her to speak
all right betsy your mic is on you're
betsy mckinney your mic is is on and
unneeded if you update you should be
okay that's it you're you're muted now
now you're you're free to talk betsy if
so brad her mic comes on but it
you may need to just leave the media and
come back in it might be as to
again uh betsy mckinney may need to
leave the call and come back in and then
ah
uh
there's no other hands
[Music]
okay there is one other person who's uh
testifying who is
there is one other person who is
testifying who signed in and support we
could go to that person
while
uh representative mckinney signs back on
okay all right i'll be looking for
uh
so
we'll try uh
we'll try nancy murphy
brad can you make sure i'm the cause
please
uh
yes
i think yeah i don't know she just said
representative murphy your mic is on if
you're right if you update you can talk
good morning mr chair and honorable
committee members
my name is nancy murphy i'm a merrimack
resident
i drafted and prime sponsored hb 737
which was passed in august 2019.
this bill was designed to help
communities impacted by the
environmental and public health crisis
residents are dealing with as victims of
pfas contamination and exposure from a
state identified industrial polluter
the intent of this bill was to address
how pfes is impacted and continues to
impact our communities based upon
ongoing daily exposure which to this day
continues uh and to take real action
beyond well and water testing and to do
something about it uh residents were
waiting for help and to be heard and hb
737 was the first step in that direction
the three towns included
for citizen representation within the
bill merrimack bedford and litchfield
were included
due to their known impacts for the same
polluter
since 737's passage we've learned from
des that london dairy is also similarly
impacted by the same polluter residents
there are as concerned about their
exposure to these toxic chemicals
as those in the other included
neighboring communities
it is important for londonderry to have
citizen representation on this
commission i've had that information
been available about londonderry's
contamination when i wrote the bill i
would have certainly included
londonderry in the original bill i ask
that you support this and vote otp thank
you for allowing me to speak
thank you honorable representative
is there any questions
the questions from the virtual
committee thank you it's tough to
hearing and seeing none
thank you
thank you representative
representative mccain never came back
upstairs oh did not come back
she's not back up on the net
uh brad is she there
from
here from your side yes
i'm not seeing her in the attendee list
that's here come back in
that's correct i haven't seen her come
back in yet to help businesses
get back on their feet because of this
how many businesses out there do you
think
you know i got a couple hundred emails
well right now we're still at a small
number of businesses directly impacted
um
it looks like the members in the room
looks like the computer
all right who who has a question now all
right
representative smith has her hand up
okay
can we hear representative smith
yeah representative uh mr chair um i
wondered if it's possible i don't know
if it's something we're doing or if it's
the way the system is set up but we're
not seeing any of the people who are
testifying
like um
uh
and i don't know if that's the people
testifying not having their camera on or
whether it's something in our system but
if we could it would be nice to see who
is testifying
so
representative mckinney
she had her camera off but she was on
the screen
uh
representative
uh murphy i could not see her but her
mic was on and her camera was off okay
so i think you can turn it on
all right but in other words sheets head
to her camera off
i will okay they'll next time
remind me that if they're if you can't
see them
so that i will
request that they turn their camera on
okay
any other
uh questions
uh
so that was raise your
can you raise your hand on the
system
there are no hands raised on the system
uh somebody's raising their hand over on
the
representative
yeah because i can't see who that is
this
representative bale is uh
okay
yeah
i just wanted to um just on a technical
basis people have to come in as um
yeah they don't have to they don't
i testified in another committee
yesterday and the chair said to me that
um he was going to move me up to
panelists so that i could speak and then
i was on the screen and then i i don't
yeah
i think it's probably
people are reading the rules different
as i see it
all committee
members should be
visible
you know this is a public meeting we are
the we are those the public
it has to seek
i think i will i will request that they
turn the testimony testifiers
turn their uh
[Music]
turn their camera on if they don't
well
we'll
we'll deal with that
if
if it becomes abused i definitely would
definitely will deal with that
and representative looks like betsy
mckinney did sign back on by a phone i
can allow her to speak if you would like
i could not understand what you said
betsy mckinney signed back on
via phone i can allow her to speak if
you would like yes allow her to speak
oh here to speak um if you need to hit
star six to unmute yes i can
i can hear you
all right uh representative kenny yeah
the floor is yours
oh i'm so sorry to bother you i don't
know what i did wrong um anyway you know
who i am and i just wanted to testify in
support of the bill i think everything
probably has been covered
but londonderry about a third of our
residents are in the zone
and
they got about 500 letters out last week
so people went calling i think it would
be nice if we had somebody on the
commission
so that we could keep them better
informed what's going on and that's all
i had to say and thank you very much i'm
i'm so sorry to be such a problem
this is our first this is our first
tries and it's good to be able to uh you
know work out our our difficulties in a
in an easy in an easy environment uh
any questions for the representative
from anyone on the on the committee i
see no one at the table uh anyone
in the on screen
i see none
if that thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you appreciate it okay thank you
uh
is you know is uh
say is there anyone in the audience in
other words
uh
can we see you know actually can we see
you can see it on the list of
participants
okay just the participants all right is
there anyone
in the audience uh who uh wishes to
speak
and and since there are no hands raised
i will uh
call the session on house bill
closed
i now would like to go into executive
session
on house bill
256.
uh
at the moment
i think you've already testified
uh is there any uh representatives who
would like to uh
uh
decide to discuss this bill or have any
about anyone from uh i could see people
here anyone on the uh
oh
representative smith
yes um thank you mr chair i just wanted
to say that i think it would be a since
we have no negative testimony and
uh all of the people who testified seem
very inclined
to want this bill passed and it's a very
simple bill that just adds londonderry
to an existing commission i think it
would be a good time to uh exact
okay
thank you
you
uh anyone else
oh and and
i've already uh
screwed up a bit i should have read
uh all those who had sent in
to uh
a
uh
the
what would be called the blue sheet
which is this a sign in
uh
on this
on this bill
and uh
i should re as a should i should read
that fourth maybe uh i can come out
i come out of executive session read it
in and then go back in how's that all
right i'm going to come out of the
executive session and i'll go just to
uh reopen the uh
the hearing just to read in the people
who have
signed on who have
signed on and support
uh nicole fordney
a member of the public
sue mullen
uh
there's an elected official
uh david muse
uh
representing
again representing like an elected
official
rockingham 29
marine moody mooney
again an elected official representative
betsy mckinney elected official
uh
represents
excuse me uh eric rathbun
a member of the public
uh nancy murphy she has spoken uh that's
it
i'll can uh
close the hearing
on
house bill 256
and reopen
the uh
the commit they'll reopen the
uh
executive session on house bill 256.
i will recognize rep representative rung
for
motion by about to pass by
representative rung
seconded by representative connors
is there any additional comments on or
none
will the clerk piece call the roll
with these the
the vice chair first
i did not hear the first person voting
you know if it were an important vote so
to speak
make sure they speak up
representative
it gets
everybody
can hear it
representative
says i representative morgan yes
morgan who says yes representative harb
yes
representative park says yes
representative crichton
yeah yes
representative crichton says yes
yes
representative
president
yes
representative smith says yes
representative smith says guest
representative spang
thank you
yes
representative spanx says yes
representative grassy
yes
representative grazie says yes
representative gotling
yes
representative gottman says guest
representative cohen
yes
representative says yes representative
representative rung says yes
representative connors yes
representative connor says yes
yes
representative bale says yes
representative kelly says yes
representative
moran
yes
representative warren says yes and chair
rene zulu yes
yes
and
uh is this the uh just first the state
of the vote
uh unanimously passed
how
many should be 12-21
uh 21 yays
and zero nays in zero negs thank you
thank you
uh
consent yes sen
all right for those who are new to this
consent means it goes on a consent
calendar
and uh
it's uh
all of the bills that go on the consent
calendar if the bill is not pulled off
okay
all right
okay i'm going to uh
close the uh the hearing on
executive he'll close the executive
session
on
anything that makes it easier
all right we are
actually
we have 20
realize
the mics are alive
and continue to be alive
so
you can
you know be you can go out
do whatever you have to do or you
sure i can view from mike can hear your
life
hey brad greenland jim cringer uh
platforms
oh yes
yeah so
uh executive committee
uh i just need to know how to
turn off the attendees for executive
committee
um what do you mean like how to not have
yeah so if it's executive committee
should they be able to hear the
discussion
so if you're executing
exec sessions are public for whoever
yeah okay that's good because she's
how about if i could just put it
you've got one right there right yep
okay
thanks
hello can you hear us here
i can hear that person
okay i can i can hear better
all right we just moved the mics closer
so we should be able to
hear each other better
okay let's try it i'm just going to run
you you want to try that mike
give me a try testing one two three
not much better oh geez oh it's not
i think it's better
it's better for me
is that a little better
yeah
can you hear me
about this one
you should be able to hear this loud and
clear
yes
representative dodge can you hear me yes
um
what do you do mike
i uh my mother and i have a small
businesses
so
[Music]
you're
you ever run into pete samuelson
he runs new hampshire machinist
out of
he lives in francetown but he's in um
he's right near uh milford
runs it like a machine shop it's it's
the size of this it's
the size of this
okay but really high end
i mean you go in his machines are like
always cranking in there
no parts yeah they're no they're not
inexpensive cnc type machines yeah yeah
okay that's probably primarily our
business like the old like what they
call an email a bridgeport email which
some of our repairs they range from
three to four thousand dollars on a real
this has been
this is like
trying to keep two balls alive
it's been another one's been challenging
but this
this committee though it's not heavy
usually we have some bills
sensitivity
absolutely the
people you know assets we've had testing
this night
you guys hear this really nice people
get along very well
anybody you know we
can you hear this mic now
yeah this one was good
i think
this one
testing can you hear me testing
that was brad looks like everybody else
is muted
representative post uh
um
so
is there any i realize this is a public
meeting and
probably the reason we do not have a
chat function is because the public
can't see it
but is there any way that
we can pose questions
or things like that when we're having
trouble
um
unmuting and things like that that we
can put
somewhere
for someone to look at
representative post i suggest just um
saying mr chair
we're having trouble hearing
or if you can't mute contact i think i
if you're having
an issue um i can step in if
extra assistance is needed
[Music]
what was happening before is that
i was not hearing any sound
and and my screen wasn't frozen or
anything
okay that might have been an issue with
the mic in the in the room then
okay
that's
right
attendees 17 panelists
okay very good
you got son
you know
i noticed that
notice neckties neckties and
masks don't go together
so
okay let's
it's not to have a house bill
call
the
as the sponsor of the bill to introduce
who wants to raise his hand i guess no
i'm
trying to get him in yeah i'm trying to
can you hear me okay
yep
thank you uh good morning mr chairman
and members of the resource recreation
develop committee
it's once again a privilege and an honor
to speak to you this morning
uh my name is representative john
mcdonald and i'm from cal district 6
which consists of the fine community of
wolfeboro
i'm here to introduce the committee
house bill
99 which addresses the issues of
seasonal platforms on new hampshire
several hundred bodies of water
this bill comes at the request of many
constituents and our own new hampshire
marine patrol
these seasonal platforms have been
repairing and growing both sides and
numbers on our public bodies of water i
believe that each of you should have
been provided an example of what the
platforms i'm talking to about
i emailed some pictures into you
um
the car seats platform ranges from a
couple hundred dollars to several
thousand dollars
and at the present time i'm unaware of
any regulations of law
concerning the placement of location of
these platforms on our public bodies of
water
during the 2020 uh house session hb 1609
came before this committee and was
passed on a vote of 20 to zero
i made its way through the house and
went to the senate and due to the covert
19 pandemic it pretty much stayed in the
senate and died
this committee made certain changes to
1609 which i would like to
have you consider to hb 99
uh mr chairman would you like me to
speak to those proposed changes for
consideration
those
so you would like me to speak to them so
i can't barely understand you i'm sorry
[Music]
you look at hb uh 99 uh
270-72-c
number three i believe you should
consider to be uh
stricken as it was in the previous house
bill that i mentioned
that's any person installing it talks
about uh blocking uh the view of
individuals
uh and then the committee also added
uh 270-72i
with the title of exemptions
and this subdivision and any rules
implemented i would say 270 colon 72
g
shall not apply to any local state or
federal government agency
such agency subcontractors or to
any conservation groups engaged in the
non-recreational execution of the duties
including but not limited to
work related to law enforcement bridging
road work pollution control
the protection of fish and wildlife or
as phil the testimony i spoke to uh if i
can just bring up the email
i spoke to uh kathleen mulcahy hampson
this morning who is the
legislative liaison and seizing hearing
senior hearing examiner with the d.o.t
she showed some concerns as the bill the
president bill was written
and i told her that i was going to
recommend suggest to the committee that
it be brought into more confirmation
with uh 1609 with the changes that i
in conclusion this bill is a common
sense a reasonable approach
which gives our new hampshire marine
patrol the necessary tools to ensure and
maintain the safety of the boating
public and the pristine conditions of
our lakes and their shorelines uh thank
you for your time and allowing me to
is there any questions
uh
by members of the committee for
representatives
i have no hands raised uh
correction
um representative mcdonald have you
submitted that written testimony online
or emailed it in
i have it but i will if you'd like me to
do that yes
please do i
hear you
uh thank you mr chair um
uh representative mcdonald are you
saying i this bill needs an amendment i
was a little hard to hear everything you
said
yes i am a representative i wanted to
come into uh
confirmation
more similar to 1609 that you folks
dealt with last session
yeah there are there are quite a few
people here who were not
um
on the committee then so what would
those what would that amendment do and
did you bring it with you did you have
it drawn up i i wasn't able to get a
hold of anyone yet this morning ma'am
i'm sorry okay thank you but it would be
you want me to talk about the changes
that would be helpful okay if you look
at our hb 99 on the first page
uh down on line 28 29 and 30. you'll see
there's a section
any person installing an active seasonal
platform should demonstrate to the
satisfaction of the director
that the placement of such seasonal
platform does not obstruct any shore
front properties view of the body of
water in which the ancient system
platform is to be installed
that was removed from 1609 by your
committee
last year and i i agree that that's that
should be removed
i believe the marine mutual does also
uh
and then in addition you added the
committee added uh some exemptions
uh
two
that i would like to have you consider
for hb
and that was titled uh 270 colon 72-i
exemptions
uh this subdivision and any rules under
rsa 270 colon 72-g
shall not apply to any local
state or federal government agency
such an agency subcontractor
or to any conservation groups engaged in
the non-recreational execution of the
duties
including but not limited to
work-related law enforcement bridging
roadwork pollution control the
protection of fish and wildlife or
[Music]
bill 1609
uh which was passed by this body
uh by this coming
in
and i compared it to house built round
nine
which is before us now to see if there
is any
differences
and i did find some
minor
what i consider minor differences
uh
the
differences that i found or was able to
find
comparing 99 to 1609
was
that
there most
uh
two additions one uh
basically
[Music]
99 which is this
item item rolling number
three
which is any person installing an
anchored seasonal platform shall
demonstrate to the satisfaction of the
director but the placement of such
anchored seasonal platforms does not
obstruct any
shorefront properties view of the body
of water
in which the anchor size on the platform
but as well as
uh now remember
it was not in
6109.
[Applause]
it reads
in such a manner that obstructs any
property owner's view of the body of
water in which it is located
and then the
other
issue
is
uh and that
not what seems to be done
from
i personally do not see much
difference detailer bills but i wanted
uh
representative mcdonald
to address
the uh
adjusted
differences
[Music]
precipitated
this uh discussion
and really
it's it's about
uh
a minor variation between
we can talk about
whether or not it needs a
uh
whether it means that house bill 99
provides a
um
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm sorry i can't hear the
representative question
yes there is a
chairman or
mr chair uh there seems to be a problem
i had a lot of difficulty hearing you
you are very scratchy i don't know if
anybody else had a problem or not but i
barely got any of your message and
evidently other people are raising their
hand also
need to back away from the mic back away
from the mic a little bit it's totally
distorted
oh okay so now tell me
no i mean i lost like i don't know how
much of that i'm sorry
you want me to go over it again
it's still
i think that would be nice
uh
basically
this there is a
difference
between
house bill
1609 which is this which is the
bill that was passed last
year
in house bill 99 there are minor
differences
brought back to the attention
of
there
there are two things
uh
a couple of things there is a
small addition to house bill 99 can
[Applause]
three it says any person installing an
anchored season platform shall
demonstrate to the satisfaction of the
director that the placement of such
anchored seasonal platform was not
obstructed
from property
the body of water in which the anchored
seasonal platform is installed
that is that where that is
added that is in 99
it is not
it was not in
also
there is
a couple of ways from that
is a small well a small
letter e
yeah it is
attached
is
the
small letter
b
and it's
letter he says
he was such a native sparkling which had
a trust in the property of people
fire and
focus
finally
oh sorry is that are other people having
no he's breaking in and out now he's
disappeared on us i don't know what's
going on yeah okay
whatever the setup was for the last
public hearing we heard maybe uh
representative renzo much clearer than
we have in this public hearing section
i didn't quite what they've been doing
he said they were just saying you were
clear last hearing and they can't hear
is
[Music]
second person
should i
take myself
off
okay am i off the screen now
yes
okay
now
all right
i don't see
you are slightly distorted but we do
hear you but not as clear as in the
i'm finding a reverberation coming
through
feedback mr we could try using this mic
and turn that mic off all right i know
this is a good mic here all right uh
is this better
if you're gonna if you're gonna use that
mic you do need to speak up though
because it seems like you're a little
far away from it but it is better
all right
yes
all right that one's uh that one is this
off
okay try this one okay how's that
much much better thank you very good all
right
well
it's a struggle
all right
what i'm what i'm saying i'll stop i'll
start over again
uh
i brought the
i look back at
uh this is this bill house bill 99 is a
uh is
a uh
is a re is
bringing is supposed to be or was
the uh
a uh
a replacement or a retread of house bill
1609 which the committee had passed
last year
20 to nothing
there i
took the liberty to go through
with the previous year's bill with uh
90 house bill 99 and there are some
differences
the
uh one the first difference is item
it's uh roman numeral three
and it says
any person installing an anchored
seasonal platform shall demonstrate to
the satisfaction of the director
that the placement of such anchored
seasonal platforms does not obstruct any
shoreline shorefront property view of
the body of water in which the anchored
seasonal platform is to be installed
that's was one apparent addition
and
from
to house bill 99
that differs from what is house bill
1609 the other addition
is
there is a about a two inches lower than
that on the again on the second page
item e
small and small letter e
and
it's it's a it goes in reads in
conjunction which with item d which
actually is uh
in both bills item e's uh small letter e
says
in such a manner that obstructs another
property owner's view of the body of
water in which it is located
okay so those are the additions to i uh
to
90 house bill 99 that
didn't uh that were not specifically in
and the third
difference
was
how the
there was a section a small section at
the end of house bill
1609 as amended which was concerned
exemptions
uh on the
in the very very end of the bill the
enforcement of this subdivision
that is
the that the that part of that
is missing
it just says the enforcement just speaks
in sixteen that is missing ins uh uh in
house bill 99
uh and it's
uh a it just ends in
penalties but not exemptions
those are the uh
items
uh
the i asked
representative mcdonald
to address that
it is not something that
i'm not certain this needs
an amendment
if we are agreeing with what is in
idaho
doubts bill 9.
so
but just be aware that those are the
slight those are the differences
that be between the bill and we can talk
about this if we when we go to exec or
there might be some
uh testimony that says
why
the why that discrepancy
or difference exists and we'll convince
the
uh convince us
to go ahead with it
representative gunski
for a question representative mcdonald
had made a comment about somebody asking
for
an amendment or language change could he
repeat that statement because i didn't
get that information it was it was kind
of humble yeah could you repeat that uh
concerning
uh someone asking i wasn't asking if
you're referring to me i certainly
wasn't asking for an amendment no he
brought up another party oh okay
if i could mr chairman uh
i received a call and i returned a call
to
kathleen mccahey hampson
who's the legislative liaison for
new hampshire d.o.t
and she was concerned as the d.o.t was
concerning the testimony in 1609
that there would be some issues
concerning them putting uh rafts and
things like that at bridge work in other
organizations
and uh that was one of the amendments
that you did your committee did uh last
year on 1609 as you
added the exemptions
and i pretty much told her that i was
going to support those exemptions if
is that our forward
there anybody else mr chairman i got one
question in
um
essentially if you say obstructs another
property owner's view
does that
like eliminates the view or is that
a small narrow piece i don't understand
how
we define obstructs and who makes that
determination
okay uh
did you uh address that uh
representative or would you like uh you
think
i guess captain dunlevy is
[Music]
yeah captain dunlop would be uh more
qualified as the head of marine patrol
to probably address that issue thank you
okay so that will be addressed by
further speaker
anyone else
anybody
anybody got their hand up in the
okay
uh
is
that being the case uh thank you uh
representative uh
and we'll
go on to who's the next representative
uh representative deshay
are you there
okay you're authorized and he's ready
uh representative
uh this is uh representative de shays i
accidentally signed up to speak i just
meant to sign up to um to support to
register and to support it but i'll say
that um i'm also from wolfeboro i'm a
representative
representing carol sixx
um i strongly support this piece of
legislation it makes it so that it's
safe for navigation
on our waters for boaters in our
community which is a
invaluable to wolfeboro our strongest
resource
economic resources the lake if it wasn't
for the lake and for people to safely
travel on that resource and to utilize
it um it would be devastative to our
entire economy we have a strong tour
tourism industry up here so that's why i
have a co-sponsor on this piece of
legislation and why i support the bill
and why i hope the committee supports
this legislation too so we can have
safer and more navigable
waterways up in our community here thank
you
and uh
thank you any questions by uh anyone
from the committee
representative post
yes
thank you
um i wanted to ask if there's a
financial component to this
uh
there was
i can i can address that there's no
fiscal note on to this uh legislation
from what i saw and um i believe it
it'll stay that way without any fiscal
note so i don't think there'll be any
fiscal impact upon the state or our
budget
can i follow up please
go ahead
uh yes so um in terms of all these um
uh big floats and things that are in the
water i do go on a water on the
waterways we have a boat
um there are lots of them um i don't
know how often they come loose or the
problems that they have but i would
assume this would take more time
of our um
the people who monitor our waterways um
and wondered if that would um have a
financial effect
um in now adding these to
um because there are so many
um
to their responsibilities
uh
i will
i can uh
i don't think uh
i think the the following speaker may be
able to answer that question yeah i was
just gonna say i think the um the next
person to testify who i believe is from
marine patrol they'll be better um
suited to answer your question but i
think it's a good question worthy of
asking
thank you
okay yeah anyway
is this was there someone else
captain dunlevy are you uh
good morning mr chairman and honorable
members of the r d committee
my name is tim dunleavy and i am the
captain of the state police marine
patrol unit can everyone hear me okay
yes excellent thank you
uh i come before you this morning in
support of house bill 99
uh and respectfully ask that you
entertain uh the amendments or changes
that have been discussed by
the chair as well as representative
mcdonald
the history behind this bill uh goes
back uh a few years as you've heard
and it it addresses what currently
exists
as
what some would consider a problem on
our public waters as it relates to
inflatable
devices particularly
trampolines icebergs climbing walls and
the like
um
the proliferation of these uh somewhat
affordable somewhat not affordable
depending upon your budget
uh items
uh has has
has raised concerns where they are
unregulated at this point
absent them being placed as a hazard to
navigation or
impeding navigation of boats
anyone who has legal access to the water
can install these in front of anyone
else's property and there's nothing we
can do about it unless they are blocking
someone's access to their own dock
so this bill would allow the marine
patrol
to enforce the installation of these
devices
and and regulate their placement
um
certainly the language in house bill 99
that that has been discussed earlier
about striking the language it refers to
impeding one's view
marine patrol would enforce the striking
of that language as it would be very
difficult
uh without further clarification to
enforce simply saying obstructing a view
certainly means just about any neighbor
could complain about the placement of
inflatable whether it's in front of
their property or not
uh
the the second change that has been
discussed regarding uh identifying
exceptions to this statute
uh was initially brought forth by dot uh
uh last year last session
and marine patrol agreed with with their
point where there are times when
bridge contractors subcontractors are
installing floats that would meet this
definition
to do bridge work so it would be an
unintended consequence um and burden on
political subdivisions to to seek
um permission for installment so we
expanded the exceptions to also include
those who might be involved in water
quality studies that use floats uh
certainly the placement of floating
nests for our loons
uh and so
those items have been captured in that
exception which i again would encourage
you to consider
um
to to go in and address representative
post question about the financial
impacts
this this statute or this language this
bill would require people to to put
their name on these floating devices and
a contact phone number
right now marine patrol spends more time
trying to track down the owner and if
they don't come to claim their property
marine patrol has to engage in the
process of bringing these devices uh to
storage facilities and then on to
the state surplus white farm uh where
they would go to state auction
so it certainly uh is in everybody's
financial interest to be able to return
them to the rightful owner and and ease
our burden of having to go through that
auction process by simply being able to
make a phone call and allow a person to
claim what is rightly theirs
so with that i'm happy to answer any
other questions but but marine patrol is
in support of
of the of the language uh particularly
as it appeared in
any questions members of the committee
okay
president posed his first representative
post you have a question the captain
yes thank you um i would like to know
how
people would
apply
for a permit
to do this um what would be the
mechanism
thank you for your question this
language does not require a permit it
simply allows the enforcement of of what
is in in the language before you
uh should a person install it uh in a
manner that is not in front of their own
property
uh perhaps extends beyond
uh the the dimensions of their
shorefront property
uh or is is placed where it impacts
navigation or the recreational uses of a
neighbor
so it's not restricting the uh surefront
property owner's ability to install it
it just allows uh
some control as to the placement and how
it impacts
yes thank you uh captain dunlevy for
taking my question
um i noticed that this proposed bill
talks about anchored
seasonal platforms and maybe you can
refresh my memory from last year
um
i remember the size and the pictures of
all these floats
do we have any regulation what if it's
not anchored and it's as big as a house
can they just put it on the waterways or
is there another provision somewhere
because i read this bill only to call
for anchored platform thank you
thank you for the question
certainly uh there are
a few and i would say it would be a very
few uh people who may launch a boat for
a day trip and bring one of these
devices along with them
uh it takes some significant planning
and work because they have to inflate
them
uh either at the ramp or and tow them
out or or inflate them out on the water
we have not seen any devices that are
used that aren't anchored in any way uh
when when they would be afloat it would
be a very temporary situation
uh and and they would fall under the
same regulations of any other floating
device that somebody may look to put out
on the water uh and and essentially it
would be a a navigation issue at that
point and and we we already have the
ability to statute to address any safety
concerns with that scenario
thank you you answered my question thank
you
anyone else uh ever have a question on
captain
representative post still has her hands
up oh no she hasn't fallen out you have
a follow-on representative post
yes i do um so normally i believe that
uh boats and docks that you're mooring
putting on an anchor
have to be approved um is would that be
the same with um these
floats that are
we're discussing
no ma'am it would not some of the
language that you find in the mooring
law
which by the way only applies to about
seven of our lakes
has been borrowed as far as
who is eligible to install these
but beyond that there is no permit
requirement
no permission that needs to be sought
this language simply allows us to
enforce
uh those things that might be installed
and misplaced or impact like i say the
the the users
that answer your question
yes thank you very much
uh representative creighton
thank you mr chairman uh captain the uh
i heard you say it but it was muffled so
i guess what was your
your take on the obstruction comment
uh currently thank you representative
currently there are statutes already on
the books that allow us to address
any placement of these devices either
floating or anchored which are impacting
i would only recommend striking the
the line that that was discussed earlier
as it pertains to obstructing a view
and then including the exceptions that
were discussed
okay thank you very much sir thank you
sir
is there any other questions of the
present more answer oh representative
moran
are you there yes yes uh uh if this um
passes what would be the fines or fees
a captain
uh yes it would be considered a
violation
uh right now there is no uh monetary
amount
uh placed on
the fine so that would be set by the
court
typically uh non-safety related uh fines
that are assessed by it by the court
where there isn't a fine schedule in
place
uh follow-up question on if a fine is
levied where do those funds go to
uh the general fund uh is my
understanding
thank you very much
okay thank you
uh there being no um more questions uh
thank you captain
uh
is there anyone else nobody's scheduled
to speak there's nobody else scheduled
thank you chairman and uh honorable
members of the committee can you hear me
by yourself and uh who you represent
yes so my name is matt urban
i represent the new hampshire department
of transportation i'm the chief of our
operations management section
i want to send a an extra thanks to
representative mcdonald and also captain
ben levy i think they've done a great
job expressing
the concerns that d.o.t initially had
and we support the proposed amendment to
carry over the language from 1609
specific to the exemptions
section uh that said that that was our
concern and i think it's been addressed
if that proposed amendment carries
through
thank you
uh is there any
anybody anybody uh
nobody here in-house anybody uh
visually
i don't know
okay thank you very much uh mr urban uh
is there anyone else which seemed to
speak
we've seen that scene none
call the weather
could you read the
let's
read the list of uh
people who
uh
that would be considered the blue sheet
so
all in support
uh all three speakers uh representative
mcdonald representative deshay
and captain dunleavy
i also have representative
marsh we have david packard
representing the lakes management
and
thank you
uh
with that i will close the hearing on
mr chairman may speak yes
i realized that um i have to leave now
of being stripped of my committee
assignment although i still remain on
the role
and the roster
i feel very sad about this i feel that
there's been a double standard
i feel my freedom of speech is being
violated
and i'm just very disappointed
i feel like i've contributed well to
this committee and i'm ready to continue
to do so
i urged all my colleagues from across
the aisle as well to speak up because
today it's me tomorrow could be somebody
else but i i really feel like i've been
mistreated
thank you
all right uh
i had planned to exec
exec this uh
bill
today obviously that's not going to
happen it doesn't require a an amendment
so i'll just put it on a future
uh
a
future calendar
which will
and we'll handle the amendment and the
executing then
uh
and with that
well first
uh
first of all i want to be further before
i just uh give you
the next 10 minutes uh we are that we
are going to have a lunch break
uh
[Music]
as we certainly don't let everyone know
that
uh and uh
there
uh and keep your wednesdays open
uh for
uh
i i
haven't heard back yet specifically on
but i have intentionally tried to get
the next the the next wednesdays until
we use up everything is who's up
everything
and that would probably be an additional
three meetings
so at least you can plan that far i hope
so
uh let you all go uh until 10 we'll
reconvene
did somebody say they were going to take
charge of putting together that number
uh they will
that's the person who suggested is going
to do it yep
oh well the person is going to do it
well
representative mcdonald is the person
who's going to be responsible for the
amendment we may
wish to get involved
and
we may have a uh
this
would be a
could be a work session but lots make
the choices on that i hadn't expected
this
but uh
it's kind of good that i
i did i i just was doing
wanted to make sure i was just checking
uh the difference because we're trying
to say that these were
bills that were
supposed to have been
the same
going uh that were passed
last year well
being you know kind of retentive i just
decided to read
both of them together
and there were
my what i still call them real minor
differences
mr chair
if we do this amendment
then the bill will be exactly the same
as passed the house on the consent
looks like
yeah
okay i mean yeah
that is that is true on the exemption
yeah the exemption was in the bill we
passed
he pretty much it looks like hb 99 is
the bill that was introduced last year
that we amended
and then we amended it and then it
passed
that's the one thing i didn't do was
look at
house bill 99
i didn't look at 1609 as committed
that
yes
representative smith has just
said that he's 99 i will check that
and
uh
speaker sent an official notice
to
the clerk
and
[Music]
others
that she was being
okay
mr chair you've got uh representative
cohen with his hand up
uh representative cohen uh
before we start danny
what can i do for you
yes representative a chairperson zooey i
respectfully ask that you please add to
the official notes of this meeting that
i disagree with the removal of
representative wrong that i believe is
not in the best interest of the citizens
of new hampshire
i guess
i mean i'm not
well
they i don't believe that you can add
the
mr chair you have kathleen murray from
okay
house bill 184
call the
but morning um good morning to you all
nice to see you all even if it's in this
strange situation hopefully in a
several months we'll be vaccinated and
we'll be back together but um good to
see you all uh thank you for hearing
this bill as many of you know this was a
bill that was passed unanimously
some about this time maybe last year
um you did field trips coming out here
which was great fun i think you do
terrific field trips hopefully you'll be
able to do those again
um
the bill basically is prohibiting
certain watercraft in marshlands in rye
and in the back channel in newcastle
you took field trips out here so you
have an idea of what that looks like
these watercraft leave pretty much
lasting damage the damage that they do
to the ocean bed and the floor does not
go away um with one tide or too tight or
three ties these marks tend to stay
there they're basically scars that will
last for years
newcastle has worked very hard
to
bolster its environment in terms of
protection um against
storm surges and climate change you know
we're an island we're about 50 percent
rock
people have worked very hard to build up
the marshlands protect them bring them
back to a good state of health and this
is one step to ensure that some of these
marshlands these sponges that protect us
from flooding um are not damaged in the
future um the same thing with rye i
think you received a wonderful letter
from representative groter um you've got
65 percent of wetland is in in rye and
again uh these are
barriers and protections against climate
climate change storm surges
they're also used by
i guess benign
recreational users for paddle boarding
for fishing kayaking canoeing and the
watercraft that we're talking about here
is very disruptive to the people who are
trying to use those non-invasive types
of recreational activities in these
estuaries and in the back channel of
newcastle so i'm happy to take any
questions i think most of you are quite
familiar with this many of you are on
the field trip that we we did last year
um i'm happy to take any questions um i
think there are some other people around
here too that may be able to answer
questions better than i if they're
become too technical
but i would respectfully ask that as you
did last year you passed this bill along
to the senate so we can continue the
discussion there and hopefully maintain
the protections that we've already put
into place for rye and newcastle
marshlands and waterways
so thank you i will take whatever
hello representative murray
yes
okay we finally got through here
i'm sorry i couldn't hear
oh yeah well we were trying to
tell you that
we had very hard difficult time hearing
you oh
well actually you're
i think you're probably too close to the
mic and it was too fast and it was too
fast but
because not really we
you know
should i recap major points uh yes why
don't why don't you
um newcastle is an island
we've worked very hard to maintain
our marshlands to their maximum health
and these types of watercraft do great
damage to the
floor of the ocean
it impacts the ability of the marshland
to protect us against storm surge and
rising water
this is one step in a larger
environmental program in rye and
newcastle to protect our marshlands um
against these sorts of issues
there's also
is this better by the way
okay thank you um
we have
recreational users kayakers swimmers
paddleboard
fishermen who use these channels and the
watercraft that's described in the bill
is very disruptive and dangerous we also
have several swimming locations in these
areas and these
these watercraft go by so quickly that
is quite a danger to the people who are
trying to use these in a non-invasive
fashion so we're looking to protect the
people who use these in this
non-invasive fashion and we're this bill
as i said is um
an important step in protecting the
environment um for newcastle which is
subject to flooding since we are at
island we're about 50 percent rock and
new castle where you have about 65
percent of the wetlands and again um
important areas that need to be
protected um against flooding
is that better
just a quick question for you do you
have the definition of personal
watercraft that's being used for this
bill
it's basically the jet ski
it's defined in the rsas before this
bill is based on a bill that was passed
two years ago i believe
in hampton and seabrook
and the
the definition isn't included right here
it's included i think in the section
before this i don't have it with me i
can probably look it up quickly but it's
essentially it does not pertain to your
typical motor boats with a with a motor
that's attached on the back
um it's the jet ski that has that type
of
motor where the water is pushed out from
underneath and leaves deep channels in
the bottom of the the ocean floor of the
floor bed
great thank you so much
the personal water
craft there i think there is a
definition in the overall in the statute
that this is just
the way the bill was written
you see only a small section
uh
anyone else any question by anyone else
there is
uh representative kelly
uh representative kelly you have a
question
yes mr chair um i i have the rsa with
the personal watercraft
uh definition in front of me if you'd
like i can read it for the
committee
uh
it would be helpful as long as it isn't
big thing yeah it's quite short
personal watercraft means a motorboat 16
feet or less in length that is propelled
by jet pump not propellers where the
operator and riders stand kneel straddle
or sit on rather than inside the craft
okay
thank you very much that that's helpful
any uh
any other questions by members of the
committee
not only
seeing none
thank you very much representative
uh who is
uh representative uh representative brow
jc growth wrote
g-r-o-t
g-o-t
okay he's not here
i have miles cook on with his hand up
okay well first one see if the any other
the representatives the next we have uh
captain tim dunleavy out there with
marine control and we also have miles
cook
good morning mr chair again tim dunleavy
captain with the state police marine
patrol unit
uh
honorable members of the committee
marine patrol
is aware of this legislation we support
it uh we are prepared uh in conjunction
with the
port authority to to post this area
this is a shallow area
very susceptible to to tide fluctuation
and at times at low tide uh this is an
area that is one could consider high and
dry
and at high tide it is very shallow
uh and in places it would only be these
jet propelled type craft that even could
operate uh in waters of this depth
uh for those of you who may be generally
familiar with with portsmouth and
newcastle it's the back channel
that runs from roughly wentworth by the
sea marina
uh up through the back channels uh to uh
pierce's island uh in in in that area
jobs creek is another popular spot uh in
this area
so it's not a huge impact to have global
waters for personal watercraft operators
and it is sensitive area that is being
protected
and i'm happy to answer any questions
you may have
is there any questions
of the captain or members of this
committee
uh
miles cook is the next one sir no other
questions
okay
next person uh up is
miles cook speaking in favor or
opposes okay in opposition
representing himself a member of the
public uh miles cook representing
himself member of the public
uh good morning representatives this is
miles cook can you hear me
no actually
you're
uh can you back off from the microphone
uh is that a little better oh yes much
better okay
um uh good morning representatives thank
you for having me captain dunleavy it's
good to hear your voice again
um just uh would like to ask a couple of
questions of representative murray and
of captain dunleavy
i own
watercraft and i live in the dover area
i'm also
i own a couple of businesses that are
involved in this and the sales and
repair of watercraft on the seacoast
area
i understand thoroughly how these uh
these machines operate
um
having worked on them having been
involved in the in this industry for
gosh 21 years now
on the seacoast
and
uh there's not a lot of members i just
found out about this uh bill yesterday
and uh you know we have as you can
imagine we have dozens probably actually
at this point hundreds of customers
uh in this area that own and operate uh
personal watercraft
and um you know as much as
as a concern i have about this bill i'd
like to look at this as an educational
experience uh for me because uh
i'm unaware of anything that a
watercraft can do
uh to negatively affect the environment
that isn't already illegal
um i you know my understanding is is
that uh representative murray made a
statement about these these machines
passing very quickly
as you may be aware rsa 270 already
covers
yeah
whether boats have to operate boats
include watercraft have to operate at
headway speed within 150 feet
of any shoreland uh areas so if there is
an area that is
exposed as
due to low tide as the representative
was talking about
uh that area they would have to be
operating at headway speed they could
not go through there quickly and that
would be you know kevin dunley please
correct me if i'm wrong but that would
be
something that they could be cited for
um and banning uh you know an entire
user group of people
uh citizens in this area uh due to
you know
due to issues that may or not be
substantiated
uh i have i have great concerns with and
and i'm wondering what
evidence that we might have that
determines that has determined that the
wave runners and watercraft are creating
this damage they do operate with a jet
pump they do not have propellers
boats have you know propellers on them
and the propellers are what creates the
the majority of any damage to to the
substrate uh in this in these areas and
um i don't understand if there's been
if there is real evidence out there that
that's uh showing that the wave runners
and the watercraft are doing this i'm
happy to look at it and i'm happy to
educate our customers
but until this bill and representative
murray's explanation i'm unaware of any
of this so
if she could help me and help me out and
explain some of this i would really
am i good to talk
nope uh does uh either representative uh
murray or captain don levy wish to uh
um am i can you hear me am i ready to
respond
mr chair
this is representative smith i have i
object um people who come to give
testimony to
at a public hearing don't usually get to
ask other people who are giving
testimony questions
usually it's the representatives who get
to ask the questions others are just
observers
that that is true but i was just
allowing uh the representative or
captain to respond if they wished
i would only say that there is a video
which i would be glad to send um mr
miles uh which shows the damage from jet
skis
okay i'm happy to see that i would very
much like to create a dialogue with you
guys with you representative murray
outside of this committee meeting
um the the idea that that a jet ski
could create damage to the substrate in
protected and sensitive areas
this doesn't make sense to me and i'm
and i'm informing that the committee of
this and if if i know that we're saying
that they damage areas and we're saying
that they're operating quickly and we're
saying
that they're disruptive but i don't know
how and and and and
i would resp
mr cook
you hear me
i said i didn't want a back and forth
i didn't want to have an argument going
on
obviously
this is my first one of these hearings
and this will not happen again
so you have representative post and
representative moran in that order
all right uh this we're still in he's
still testifying
mr cook are you finished with your
testimony
he has to arm you stand by sir
yes i'm you i apologize i'm unmuted now
i apologize i guess i was muted um
i'm sorry doing this in a zoom meeting
is difficult and i don't mean to create
the back and forth or do anything
disrespectful
um i would just suggest to the committee
that that uh you know that i have not
seen and i am unaware of any evidence to
suggest
that the wave runners are disruptive to
the substrate to sensitive environmental
areas
you're banning an entire user group from
being able to use public areas
i don't think that that is warranted
unless there is real you know
significant evidence to deter to show
that it is actually wave runners doing
the damage
and that's my you know my testimony to
the to the committee
yes thank you very much for taking my
question um i i do appreciate
the where mr cook is coming from
um and i would like to see evidence of
wave runners and jet skis do i know
there are a lot of small
smaller lakes that people have these
i haven't noticed any damage from i have
a family that does have some of those
and
i i'm just interested to see if there is
really damage created by them and if we
have laws in place
representative
yes now i can yes you have to form this
so so i would i would like to i would
like information on on
that that would be my question if we
could gather information
and how do we do that
um to see what kind of damage these
actually do have
excuse me
on the environment
this is the question of the
of the person
testified uh you know this is for
everyone uh
the you place that you when you when
fighting when you're asking you asking a
question
of the witness
you're not
telling them
stuff that you
it's not a uh
you're not telling the witness anything
you could you
still it should be
phrased in the form of a question
so
in other words this
witness so and so
what uh what is this or what are you
what is where is there any of any
thing that you could uh and you could
show can you show us any uh in the
information data
so if you you want to have so
please go ahead and uh
yeah but ask it in the form of a
question is it very difficult to be able
to
get the person's attention through this
zoom system
yes thank you i apologize for that
so my question is mr cook would you be
able to provide the committee
with any uh information on those
jet skis and watercraft that
you're speaking of and how it harms the
can the committee hear me
yes
okay all right thank you
um well that's just the the point
representative post i'm saying that i'm
unaware of any evidence to show that
that this product
uh given that it's makeup given how it's
constructed
could har could harm the environment um
and i would moreover suggest that it is
both operating with propellers and lower
units uh you know that is creating any
damage to the substrate that that uh may
occur i don't
if i could see
somehow a a a
jet pump or the the way that and i'm
happy to provide
any information that any committee
members want with regard to how these
machines operate how they are
constructed
why it is difficult for them to create
the damage that is being discussed that
is the point of topic here
i'm happy to to show that that and it's
just logically uh with the way that
these
machines are constructed it's very hard
for them to do damage to the substrate
unless they were
i mean they would have to be really
doing something that would already be
considered a leak you know improper
illegal under rsa270
so um i i don't i'm not aware of how
they're doing it so if if there's
evidence out there i'm happy to look at
it but i don't have any to show that
they would be
and representative more answer
representative moran for a question
thank you mr chairman uh mr cook
do you think this bill would negatively
impact your small business
oh absolutely
absolutely
have you had an opportunity to run any
type of numbers that would
indicate a loss of income or revenue as
a result of this bill
um no i haven't i just learned about the
bill yesterday
uh that's that's the issue most people
in this area we didn't know about this
bill uh
or i haven't heard about it and my
customer group hasn't told me anything
about it so i just know that it would
greatly diminish you know the user
the the the users of this mark of this
product in this area and any thing that
does that
uh would have a negative effect on our
small business
and uh have you been negatively impacted
by covert 19.
we were at first
but then we also sell other products um
you know off-road vehicles uh that sort
of thing and
as we got into the year uh it it seemed
like more and more people because you
can you know utilize this product in
socially distance get outside
uh go and enjoy what new hampshire has
to offer uh we actually saw a little bit
of a spike in business late in the year
uh as you know probably well not lately
mid may june early in the year yes may
june no things actually started to spike
a little bit
uh do you think this bill would uh
reduce your revenue again after
seemingly having a small increase from
the 19 impact on your small business
yeah so it would not only in the short
term but in the long term as well
do you think this bill will impact the
your local economy
yes i do
thank you
representative
procedure is you ask one question
and then when you run a follow-up you
just say follow-up and there's all
questions up to come through the chair
again this is a learning experience for
me to be able to
do this by
uh you know by zoom
uh
it's so easy if you're you know you're
here we just
talk
so
that's that for everybody that's the uh
you have to come back to the chair and
just say for a follow-up
uh
[Music]
uh any more
response
to representative we have one more
question
yes i'm here
mr chair may i please ask a question of
representative murray
uh not miss representative murder
she she presented the initial bill
with mr cook and then uh i'll ask
representative murray
uh if she will take a question
additional question uh is there any
other questions for
mr cook
i have a question
uh
who's that who is uh
mr chair this is representative linda
gould i'd like a question to ask of
miles cook
okay uh
representative gould for questions
okay a few people
okay a few people have brought up the
financial aspects to your business and i
was just wondering would you say a high
percentage of your customers actually
ski a jet ski in this particular
well it's both
we have a lot of customers in the local
area i the dealerships i own one is in
hampton and the other one is in
rochester
and we have a number of customers that
will take their wave runners and operate
in both areas
but we have a large amount of them that
do operate on the seacoast i hear
stories of them taking their families
out and their friends out and going down
the swampscott river over to exeter and
uh going through the back channels in
newcastle going over to bg's boathouse
and
you know just getting out and enjoying
the you know the summer and the weather
and and uh getting through those areas
and
this this bill would have would have a
serious impact on that and um you know i
would just hate to see that happen for
those folks
representative smith
smith
thank you mr chair and thank you mr cook
for taking my question have you um read
the bill and looked at a map of exactly
the area that it would include uh i.e
the uh
newcastle goat island back channel
mooring field
yes i have
um
[Music]
uh
here
okay uh uh
uh representative mayville you had a
question for uh
i did thank you for taking my question i
apologize for being a little bit slow on
the uptake as i'm trying to research
through this as a new member of the
committee
would you be willing to offer um or
provide some type of
research or articles that demonstrate
that the rave the characteristics of the
wave produced by these personal
watercraft
affect the turbidity of the water and
therefore affect the erosion
of that substrate i'm just unaware of
any and i was unable to quickly research
and find something that demonstrated
that because it appears that this is um
expanding the area of limitation on
these personal watercraft so i would
like to see something that's that's
demonstrating that the um the propellant
of these watercraft you know exhibited
at speed is damaging that substrate
can you hear me
uh yeah
um there was a lot of work that was done
on this last year and as i said the bill
was passed unanimously uh with the field
trips that the committee took it was
also a video that was done to show the
kind of
the the area the shallowness of the area
the sensitivity of the substrata and the
damage that
these type of watercraft can do i'd like
to iterate that this is a really small
area and in particular bee gees is not
effective that's well beyond this area
this is a very small area where it's
very shallow
and very environmentally sensitive
it does not affect
very many people at all coming in here
and the idea is that they
inadvertently might come in there and
the damage is you know pretty lasting
but i can i'm sure i can dig out that
video if you wanted and there's a great
deal of information um that and
testimony from last year um around this
issue from des i think from marine
patrol
and i think a lot of people here already
saw it with the
representative mabel did you have
does that answer your question
it does thank you i'm sorry i was not on
the committee last year i did not attend
those field trips and so i'm simply
seeking information but i appreciate the
response
okay
uh
yes
i'd like to uh a question of
representative murray if i could a
question of representative murray near
you
representative murray
i'm here
a question by representative
good morning representative thank you
for taking my question uh representative
smith had uh just brought up a few
moments ago with another speaker about a
map
and i recall
you providing us a map last year
when we heard this
this
similar bill
is it possible for the committee to get
a copy of the areas that you have
designated in this bill
i'm i'm sure that there is i don't know
if you still have a copy from the from
the previous year you know materials
that were attached to the bill
but i'm sure i can find the the map
again this year
serenia uh who's uh
so there are no other no other hands
raised
are there any other uh is any other
there are no other speakers
there being no uh are there any is there
anyone else in the uh audience
who
nobody's raising their hand right yeah
sure okay that being the case
we'll close the hearing
sir stand by you have uh representative
smith has your hands up all right uh
is this while
uh i'll get a hold for representative
smith
uh you have uh
yes i had a question for captain
dunleavy
captain dunleavy um i know that uh the
bill that we passed last year
uh
refined the area that was going to be um
included in the bill
and uh could you tell me what the the
water depth is in those areas and and
what the damage is that is has been
being talked about
uh ma'am i can i can speak to the the
water depth in that it varies with the
tides again there are times when when uh
this is high and dry
uh depending upon the tide height uh it
could be it could range from six inches
to a couple of feet in some of these
areas
uh it depends on how close to shore you
are
rather than how close you are to the to
the navigable channel
uh as far as the damages are concerned i
i i don't have the science uh i i don't
feel qualified to speak to the science
i do know that certainly at times of
tide
uh these are shallow areas that are
difficult for
our
regular patrol craft to access due to
the fact that they are prop driven and
there just simply isn't enough water
depth
okay
thank you and oh um captain dunleavy uh
oh follow-up question
mister
um
the the discussion of uh
what
motor which watercraft we're talking
about
could you describe how the propellers
work or how the how the water is uh
funneled through the motor or the engine
on these watercraft
certainly i'd be happy to uh
this is a jet pump or a jet propelled
craft by definition
and essentially the engine of these
machines
through a grate in the bottom of the
machine
sucks in
the water and through an impeller im
color
pushes a jet of water through a nozzle
uh out the back of the machine so it is
it is it is water pressure that is
pushing or propelling this machine and
this nozzle will go side to side which
accounts for the steering
so there is no hardware such as a shaft
or a propeller or a rudder
or a lower unit
beneath the surface of the hull of this
machine
yeah um
so that because there is no propeller
sticking out then they can go in much
shallower water than other
moto watercraft
correct
that is accurate this is a very shallow
what we refer to as a shallow draft
craft but the water is still powerful
it it
depending upon how much throttle is
applied certainly
uh these these it does push that machine
thank you
um my question is about the pressure of
the water and how like how fast is this
water coming out and
how many pounds per square inch are we
talking about that would move a machine
mr chair would you like me to take it
this is tim dunleavy
yes
so so the the amount of uh pressure or
um
speed of that jet pump is is all
relative to a variety of things
i will tell you that if if a person is
applying full throttle to this machine
we're talking machines that run probably
80 to 85 horsepower uh up to probably
for the more common models
uh and some of these machines uh will
range in speed from
35 40 miles an hour maximum uh probably
upwards to 70 or 80 for the higher end
and maybe even more
for a larger machine
um specifically pressure or or speed of
of the water at the pump
uh i
i don't have i don't have that knowledge
yes thank you
representative moran served next
yes i did
i am all set with questions thank you so
[Music]
i was wondering if anyone can you hear
i can hear you
um i i was wondering if anyone knows if
this has been um put forth because of um
i know they went on a a trip last year
and what kind of damage that was
was anyone on the trip last year
everybody we are having technical
difficulties the main system here went
down
hello
yeah
this is andy chairman
uh
[Music]
we're
we're off on this side
the screen is
so
all right i'm gonna turn my volume back
down
all right where's
yeah it just died
it's greener greenland
yeah
open up some
windows okay no so long as the windows
would be yeah you can open them up
at least
if it doesn't bother you just leave them
but yeah you know if it doesn't bother
you
huh
oh yeah but yeah
oh
brad are you still on yes i am i'm sorry
i was communicating with my other
committee as well because they're having
the same issue
okay yeah we had a uh
we had a shutdown here the main system
so
okay
[Music]
no just if she's if there's no
not
we are basically down one committee
at this as of that time
she's
not on the phone
at on the minutes no no no
[Music]
okay
right now since this is
chairman renzullo
right now we are
our system is down so i'll
recess for
the
meeting for five minutes and probably
so
okay yep i'll turn my speaker
[Music]
okay we are unmuted so we should be back
up there
okay
there's three people
all right we're
starting up again
you know
what are they saying the land of the
blind the one-night man is
that's what i did for a living believe
me
so sir you've got representative moran
with his hand up
okay
uh representative moran
thank you mr chairman i have a question
uh dunleavy are you back
i am back and available yes sir thank
you okay thank you very much for bearing
with us
uh
representative moran for a question
uh captain uh how um would you be able
to tell us how
many people
utilize this area with just get skis
maybe observations for yourself or your
team
sure it's it's a common uh
the back channel is is common
uh
channel if you will for a lot of
commercial fishing boats uh those that
use the mooring fields along the
causeway out to newcastle uh it does
several marinas uh one was bg's
boathouse which is a restaurant
while those channels aren't necessarily
falling under this restriction it would
be what i would refer to as the shoulder
waters uh for this back channel and and
some of the small islands that you would
also observe from the causeway uh would
be included in that area uh there are
several um
uh paddle craft operations rental
operations in there sea kayaking uh so
you're you're seeing a a
a very good mix of the type of
watercraft that use the area
and would you say these jet skis would
uh in your opinion have you seen these
jet skis being used to impact anyone
else's um
business that may operate in these these
wetlands
we do not see a lot of personal
watercraft traffic in that area
there is some
it is it is one of several
routes that a person can take from the
main piscataqua river to reach the open
waters of the atlantic
so
you know depending upon what route the
person chooses uh they may or may not
use these waters
so it's it's it's a variety of levels uh
it is not
um
overwhelmed with any one specific craft
thank you so much
and sir representative post
uh representative post for a question
thank you very much um this is for
captain dunleavy
have you
seen damage to that area
from any kind of craft and if so what
has that damage been
i i must confess representative that i
don't spend a lot of time uh on patrol
down there myself i have in the past
uh and i don't think that i could speak
uh or or have the qualifications to
speak to
environmental damages or the impact of
of what these machines would have on the
environment uh i just don't have that
expertise ma'am
no more
any more questions
or is there anyone from
the audience who has not spoken which is
i will
remote
testifying
testifying sheet
besides the people who spoke
jackie throat
uh
elected official from right
uh also legislator
and uh eric rathbun
is
the position uh wrath been supported and
broke support
that's it
uh hearing is
five up
uh
i had
originally considered a place where i
placed enough time
to put this bill
to
[Music]
i don't think that's going to happen
advisable
we will
hope to
right
maybe i should i will look to
uh continue
the maybe i i think i will
i think i'll reopen the hearing
and then continue it
on to another day
just so that additional information
can be gotten to it seems there's
appears to be
some
questions that need to be by some
representatives
[Music]
i don't want to
i realize we have heard the bill the
and it was a 20 to nothing vote however
all fairness and the new folks they have
questions
i
think
if they deserve to get
answers to their questions so
i will
uh
i will just continue this bill to a time
to to a future
committee uh
meeting in the future
have a uh a continuing hearing
continues so
we open the uh
i'll open the hearing and
close it i'll just recess it to
a
[Music]
that should be it i think
any questions what i just did
so you have no hands raised okay
uh are you ready for lunch
well everybody i'll raise your hands at
once
okay i don't really have a question but
it's still difficult to understand you
represent chairman renzolo
and i notice another head is shaking
also
what
you seem to be further away from the mic
candy
first hearing we had in the first part
of this last hearing you were fine after
we got you a little bit away from them
if you changed mike's but
yeah mike seems to keep moving
so
it's very faint yeah
okay and uh
we'll change back
we'll change back aft uh after lunch
yeah it's almost as if you're way in the
distance just like in the picture on the
screen
probably try to get yeah one okay maybe
the settings you could probably put that
at the end
because
no no that works that one works the best
that was done right
seven years ago our forefathers brought
forth in wisconsin and a new nation
dedicated the proposition that all men
that's it
good enough
well tell me somebody i don't know
yeah it's not 100
not 100
it it hasn't changed a lot andy i think
you just raise your voice and speak
louder we can hear you better but it's
still your
you were much closer to the mic at one
point there we were hearing you fine and
now it's sort of falling off a little
bit
right again okay how's this
uh you're starting to get distorted now
so you're back to that second area we
had where we couldn't understand a word
you said
okay
one two three four
better much better again it's acceptable
i think it i think it's good considering
the circumstances we can always always
put on headphones on our side
okay uh we'll do as best we can as we
we struggle through it now you know what
will happen when you go
off to a zoom meeting so
this was for half
people it's crazy there's a chair i
think part of it is when you leave back
yep
don't leave your mind just if you just
stay in the same spot stay in the motion
yeah
you have to get something to measure
i wonder if i put my mask over it
anyway
going back to my o'clock and logging in
at least
i don't have a problem with it
jim i didn't even realize that uh
that little that little shelf under
there until i saw you put your coffee on
right there
yeah that's always like people do that i
can you hear me lisa
yes i can
eagle's nest
that's pretty cool do you have any of
those in your house
a couple other clothes no i used to live
my uh my company was called eagle point
what do you do jim
yeah
we're both i'm sorry about two gyms
well you got you said you're meeting
this evening what are you i work at a uh
so i i'm a retired colonel from the army
and i own two businesses
one eagle point
global solutions which is a leadership
security consultancy
and then i own ursa major north
northeast guides which is a
wilderness guide company
work with wounded warriors and we do a
um
[Music]
is
wanted me to just let everybody know the
schedule for the next three weeks
is now out
and we'll be having our hearings uh on
wednesdays
we are just waiting for the uh for the
and you have six attendees
six offendees
um
did i ask if um we will have
each week a new zoom to click onto
or can we use this the one we have today
provide a new link every week okay thank
you
i have a question also
uh will we be getting our the bills on
hard copy at home
i have not received man yet i copied out
a couple but
um
do you think we'll be getting hard
copies or not
uh they said they were uh
they i was told
that they were sending they were mailing
them out
the
i guess uh
somewhere in the 500s or above
they don't have
a lot of copies made
even for this meeting
uh
they had to they had to make these
copies uh for
here
so they don't have a lot of uh
[Music]
they don't have a lot to mail out
but they said
that they all i know is they said
they're made they were mailing they
mailed some out oh they bailed them out
monday what they had monday
i haven't checked my mail today to see
if they came yet but they we didn't get
them here i didn't get them either here
yeah
because yeah i didn't i didn't get uh i
didn't get them uh yesterday i don't
know
so nobody has anybody looked in their
mail already
we get a break between this meeting and
the next i'll go check my mail
okay i did check and i don't have them
i don't have i don't have them either
okay well
we'll have another week
before we have to worry about it
you know worry about what's left
uh
i'm going to turn the uh
uh this is we aren't started yet i'm
just uh
look and as mike just said we uh we have
the
the schedules around i just checked the
uh email and uh
heather has put out the schedule for the
next three meetings
one uh
it's a wednesday the third the 10th the
17th
and by then that's all our meetings
that's it we've got we'll done all the
builds
and you know but that's
firing
uh anything happening like
uh oh you know
i had expected to do three bills today
he completed but i've only got one so
far
this is going to have to be a little
ketchup so
there's a 3 44 i will be turning the
gavel over to
mike
godski vice chair because i
am
okay with that i just wanted to make
sure can everybody hear me
yes
i'd like to open up the hearing for
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee
my name for the record is suzanne smith
i represent the towns of plymouth hebron
and holderness grafton county district 8
and i'm here as the prime sponsor of
house bill 344
relative to temporary docs
this bill was a request of the
commission to study structures in or on
non-tidal waters otherwise known as the
dock commission
and this bill amends three statutes that
relate to docs
and their
i'd say their housekeeping but that's
usually the kiss of death for a bill is
to say it's housekeeping um in the the
part one of the bill um if you have a
copy of it it's on line three
just clarifies that it is not just
seasonal docks we're talking about its
temporary seasonal docks just in case
there's any confusion on the part of the
public
part two
uh
removes
rivers
from the statute that allows you to just
get a permit by notification
uh which means you just write a letter
to des and you can put in your doc
without any uh
any bureaucratic
tape
and so it just excludes rivers from this
statute because rivers where the water
is flowing you would not want a dock
heading straight out into a river
uh it could cause damage to boats damage
to the environment
and damage to the dock so it just
removes rivers from temporary seasonal
dock statute that we already have
and then the third part of the build
which is line 17 pertains to the doc
registration criteria we passed a doc
registration process
uh in 2020
and this just clarifies that if you wish
to use the doc registration process
to
install your new doc
if you have pending
or final adverse action from a municipal
or state authority or pending civil
action you cannot use the doc
registration process to get your new doc
so that is the gist of the bill i can
try to answer questions but i'm hoping
that there are people from in the uh
audience wishing to speak that can
clarify it better than i can
thank you representative smith are there
any questions
from
[Music]
representative smith did you hear that
question
it was asked could you
email your testimony to the committee
i don't have anything written i could
write something up quickly but i don't
okay thank you
okay questions none thank you
next we have
darlene forrest
from the
department of environmental services
um quick sound check can you guys hear
me
yes thank you
uh my name is darlene forst i'm the
existing shoreline section supervisor
within the wetlands bureau and shoreland
program at the new hampshire department
of environmental services and i am
testifying on behalf of the department
this afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to speak
i did email
a copy of the departments of fiddle
official letter of testimony to
supplement today's discussion which you
should have received this morning
this bill
corrects
language that was changed unfortunately
last year
last year within the
structures on public waters commission
there was a discussion about expanding
this process to include rivers this
process is an exemption from the
permitting requirements specific to
certain single seasonal docks
and they're seasonal docks which have no
anchor constructed at the shoreline
so they're for stillwater areas
where you're really just setting a
structure in place that you can tie a
boat to or walk out and fish off of
so there was a discussion of adding
these two rivers and streams and
that may have seemed like a good idea at
the time but after some discussions and
after the after the bill was introduced
and discussions with the new hampshire
rivers committees
it was decided that such a dock which
has no modification of the bank would be
unstable and be a potential safety
hazard on a river or stream because it's
likely to break free
especially in times of flood and where
we have so many dams in this state if
something were to break free with a boat
attached or without a boat attached it
all ends up in some dams rack
downstream it becomes a safety hazard it
puts stress on on that dam or it ends up
in someone else's frontage or it becomes
a
hazard to boaters or swimmers elsewhere
down current
so it was intended that
when the bill which added this language
this exemption to rivers and streams it
was intended that when it reached
the opposite side of the legislature
after crossover it would be amended and
those those provisions would be removed
but unfortunately
as we all know last year's sessions were
somewhat interrupted
and the bill slipped through without an
opportunity to correct it and remove the
rivers and streams
provisions
so that's how we got to this point and
why that correction needs to be made
again our biggest concerns here when
they came up were
public safety concerns specific to the
fact that this exemption prohibits docks
it only applies to docks that don't have
an anchor at the shoreline and those are
exactly the docks that you don't want to
have on a flowing body of water where
something might break free and it's
where it's most likely to be a risk
so we support this
sorry that we couldn't get it cleaned up
last year but we very much support this
language change for this year
i'm happy to ask or answer any questions
for anyone if they have them
um
okay thank you
now we uh we can open it up for
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you sir
is there anybody
online that would like to testify and
like to close the uh public hearing on
okay we're going to open up the
executive session
yeah there's some discussion in hb 344.
anybody have any questions information
anything online
no sure okay
it appears to me that this is uh i
this is an executive session so i am
as a co-sponsor
of the bill
allowed to speak
and
is also the
other
member
of the uh
who is on the bill
is representative mcconkie at the time
well he is the chair of the uh
of the commission that this bill
uh emanated from
and
and the bill before it was as was really
the basic
uh
basic law that this
finished polishing up
other than that
don't they have
okay
[Music]
we have the motion
we have a motion of ought to pass on hb
[Music]
um okay representative gunski yes yes
representative gunston says yes
representative gould
representative gold says yes
representative corrigan yes
representative horgan says yes
representative harper
yes
representative park says yes
representative crichton
yes yes
representative crichton says guest
representative dodge
yes
representative dodge says yes
representative harvey voglia yes
um representative healey yes
yes
representative mabel rebuilds as yes
representative
representative post says yes
representative post says yes um
representative smith yes representative
smith says yes representative speng
representative spanx says yes
um represent grassy
yes
okay representative cohen says yes
representative rob
oh
um representative connors
representative connor says yes
representative bail
yes
okay representative bale says yes
representative kelly
representative kelly says yes
representative moran
uh yes
representative um
representative ronzolo yes yes
so um that is 20
pas
and passes
now we'll close the executive session
well uh
oh actually
let me have a second
sure
i'll read the tally uh you have darlene
porch she testified suzanne smith
testified
and eric rathbun
a member of the public
[Music]
is
not justified
okay
uh
google
representative smith
would you write the blurb on me
on hb 344
it was off the hook but yeah no i can do
that
thank you
when do we need the
committee report
uh
that's
you can have a weekend to work on it
so
give you a lot of time
okay i'll turn the gavel back over to
chairman prinzulo all right when
actually we now have uh
35 minutes 35 minutes
um
does something happen between this
morning and this afternoon because all
of a sudden
it was
it was this long going to the first
three minutes three committee
hearings and now this one bang like that
amazing
must be mike you're gonna have to take
the chair no i'm good
it's got to be me
so
don't hold your breath handy don't hold
your breath
this channel i'm going to put us on you
uh yeah uh we'll just uh
we're
we're adjourned so
you still have that
mr sharon you're welcome
okay
get that food up
mr chairman you have six attendees
six attendees and two zero
um
okay
can you can you hear me now
yes no
guess we can hear you
193 relative to penalties for improper
timber harvesting
and
[Music]
thank you mr chair
and hello again members of the resources
recreation and development committee
um for the record i'm suzanne smith i
represent the towns of plymouth hebron
and holderness grafton eighth and i'm
here as the prime sponsor of house bill
193 house bill 193 relative to
timber trespass laws
was introduced last year as a different
bill it was amended and cleaned up and
passed this committee unanimously passed
the floor on the consent calendar
went to the senate where covid hit and
it was tabled
so um i have took the liberty of
reintroducing it because it is an
important bill it does not change the
penalties
for taking timber timber trespass which
is usually if there's a logging job
being done if someone uh cuts trees
on someone else's property they are
liable and that is in the statute now
what this bill does is it also changes
it somewhat so that
if you are the owner
of the property and you tell the logger
these are all my trees over here these
two acres over there cut those and
they're really not your property
the logger is not liable you are liable
because you told them to cut them there
so who's ever responsible for the trees
being cut whether it's the log or the
forester or the owner
it would make them liable for the timber
trespass not just the person who is
doing the actual cutting
and that's all that the bill does
it does not change the penalties that
are already in place
and i will take questions if you have
any
sure
i will take a question
currently
if a landowner tells a logger to cut
land on someone else's property who's
correct
who is is it water's responsibility for
the
if for example i have 20 acres
and i want to log
10 of them
and i misrepresent the property and half
of that property is not mine it's on my
neighbor's property
then i would be liable if this law
passed
for telling the logger that is my
property when it wasn't my property
and i believe that someone i'm hoping
someone from a department of forest and
lands is here or
jason stock from timberland owners to uh
help me out if that needs to happen i
don't see them on the list of attendees
though
but yeah that is that is what the law
would do it doesn't it's just that if
you're
if you're in good faith the logger and
someone tells you that you that it's
their property
it's their responsibility to know what
it they own
i'm not hearing any questions are there
questions
uh no we're just i was just trying to
determine
okay
actually two hands raised i do have a
question
yes i do and thank you for recognizing
me um i would like to know if that
creates a situation up
he told me the other one refuses it how
how
would we balance that how would you know
make that determination
about who said what
on something like that
yeah i don't i mean
when you
file an intent to cut order
it goes through the
municipality
and you state on it how many acres you
have and how much you're going to have
cut
so
i would i mean i'm not
i'm only looking at the statute i have
in front of me which is what the
penalties are
and who is responsible i don't i don't
know for sure how
i don't know the fine points there
so i can't answer that question
without saying that if you own property
maybe i might help out a little bit on
that
but
this is uh
these are basically
we can't i can't really hear anyone in
the room
all i can hear are the zoom people
and we cannot hear the room
here
can't hear you mr chair
can you hear me
coming through is muffled and not
legible
you're getting your exercise today
yeah
how's that
better good that's good oh okay
they heard
yeah that one works that works yeah
i think just uh
all this is doing is
uh
laying out
alexa
okay
somebody's been unmuting us for some
reason it's
well i was just muted and i unmuted
myself and i was i was muted and
somebody unmuted me
and the the whole general room is now
muted
the in-person people are muted and poor
representative harb's ma hand is
probably getting tired from holding up
representative smith i appreciate you
recognizing my hand we should probably
be
conversation without the main room
i know well the chair has to
they have to get their act together well
it looks like they're unmuted now
i think
i think maybe representative
might be
trying to help being a practicing
attorney you might
want to respond to what the question is
concerning
well
mr chair thank you very much for
recognizing me um i don't want to get
into details with the evidentiary
question but that is what the court and
the judge would decide who said what and
what was documented
but i do have a question if you could
take it um representative smith taking
my question for the sake of clarity as
the chair mentioned i i am a practicing
attorney i think if you would entertain
making a motion
on article one and to add before you
bold or cause
add negligently because i think by
deleting and not inserting negligently
it leads me to question
what's the
level of cause there so it's in the
first part no person shall negligently
cut my suggestion is or negligently
cause
i would add the same comment to article
2.1
that says
or cause to be cut that article says
recklessly
though i would ask if you would
entertain putting a an amendment or
recklessly cause
that would then be consistent with the
first part of the article um
as a practicing attorney i think by
putting the karma in there it doesn't
carry forward the negligently or
recklessly
i think it's your same intent but it
would be clearer to put it in thank you
right right
yeah i as the notes i have written down
from uh thank you representative harp
the language that is
in here now mimics the slash law which
we already have in place
i mean i believe that is what um
that is what i have written in my notes
so
i would want to check with uh i mean
it's fine with me to do it means we
can't execute today it means we have to
i would i'm hoping someone is going to
have
is going to speak oh yes
speak on this and they may be able to
clarify that this indeed does work this
i want to go back to representative
certainly
the question has been asked
um yeah
for the most part i just find it's a
confusing
statement you know
that
you'd have to have some way to show
the person misrepresented it
either the landowner or the timber owner
the timber person
well
just that the law
negligently
i can explain this a little bit um mr
chair if you're negligent
it's a civil penalty
it's and negligent means you weren't
really paying attention and you cut it
by mistake
and then reckless is worse than
negligent it's a criminal offense
because it states that you did know it
and then there's knowingly which is
worst and that is purposeful and those
are all terms that are defined in
statute
and the reckless
one is a criminal offense and it's a
class b felony
if the loss is
less greater than a thousand dollars the
civil penalty the fine is between three
and ten times the cost of the the value
of the timber that was taken
yes thank you
yes okay
jason stock
the chair recognizes jason stock
thank you uh
for the for the record my name is jason
stock on the i'm i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire timberland
owners association and
we
come today
to testify in support of house bill 193
we supported it last year and as was
stated earlier this was a victim of the
disruption of last year's legislative
session
we think the the bill adds continuity to
the law
um to the
to the deceptive forestry law when i say
continuity and consistency
i'm using those interchangeably but it
adds that
consistency continuity between those
this law and the
slash laws
we also believe that it does provide
some flexibility for enforcement to
actually go in
and if there is in fact a timber
trespass
and really the party at fault is is not
the the actual logger themselves they
were
misinformed
um it gives enforcement the authority to
go and
actually pursue the party that was
responsible for the
for the actual trespass
i've spoken you know as a as a landowner
association
we also we represent the landowners but
we also represent loggers consulting
foresters as well as mills and when i
speak
discuss this bill with
loggers and foresters
they all they have everyone seemed to
have a story of a situation where
the landowner said all right yep i own
to the backstone wall and
that's that's the extent of my ownership
and they conduct a timber sale and turns
out they didn't own to the backstone
wall
and
right now the way the the law reads is
the only individual that is that
division of forest and lands can pursue
can pursue is the individual that that
cuts
cuts or carries away that timber in this
case the logger this will enable
the
this will enable the division of forests
and land in those forest ranges to say
all right let's dig a little bit deeper
let's see who really was responsible and
was this was this parcel misrepresented
and uh so again
due to the the fact that we think that
adds it adds some clarity it gives that
flexibility and it really enables the
the forest rangers to pursue who is
truly at fault
we we come today in front of you and
testify in support of house bill 193.
with respect to the the idea of changing
and inserting the word recklessly
i would really want to defer to
the the folks in the division of forests
and lands
i am not an attorney
but i do know that
negligently recklessly and on purpose as
representative smith had said
those do have different
uh different weights and represent
culpable states of mind and i would
before we
before the committee execs and approves
this bill i would really want to hear
from the
folks in enforcement
if that
how big a change or shift that would be
by inserting recklessly in there
um
because i know there are
again as representative smith had
mentioned there are different
thresholds it also affects whether it's
a civil versus a criminal penalty
and
i think it'd be
wise to hear directly from the agency
that enforces this
uh
what the insertion of say recklessly
would in fact do to this due to the bill
so
um having said that again i i come today
before you and testify in support of
house bill 193 as as it's drafted and
i'd be happy to try and answer any
questions
is there any questions for uh mr stock
there are no hands-on questions
okay
anybody
the chair has a question in your
testimony
uh
i think i heard you say that right now
it's
the usually that the only person that
that the division of forests and lands
goes after is the logger
and this would allow them to go after
the
the person behind the logger
when i spoke to the rangers about this
and we had this discussion last year
right now the way the law is written is
the only person under a civil
penalty they can pursue
is that individual that cut fell
destroyed injured or carried away
the tree
in that
in essence the logger
and there are instances and
circumstances where the logger may not
be the party that's rep that really is
responsible for that tree
being cut
or carried away um it may in fact be the
landowner that misrepresented it or the
forester
that misrepresented the ownership to the
logger and so this gives the division of
forests and lands
it allows them the flexibility to yes
look at the logger but also in their
investigation look at these other
parties that are involved in that
transaction
got that
thank you anybody any uh any qualm
further questions
you don't have any questions
okay
then
thank you very much uh thank you
uh
is someone from uh forest and lands uh
available
uh
i thought i saw a
comedy
all right
patrick instead of mr hackley are you
there
i thought he uh i thought i saw
uh some
on the list of emails
that he was uh that sent something in
but i gotta have to switch screens for
that and he just took his fingernails
oh
exactly
um
chair
i i do have that up on my email he did
he's trying to come back in
okay
hello
there you go
you can hear me now yes again hear you
doc uh
could you uh could you help us out and
testify
or
give us your
you've heard the testimony so far uh
could you could you comment please
sure i'd be glad to just bear with me
i've got um
a very really weird echo on my computer
right now
um
thank you very much for allowing me to
testify before the committee
um i i think the discussion's been
excellent if for those of you who've had
a chance to review my testimony
submitted earlier
yesterday
we are in support of the bill
as proposed
um i don't think the addition of the
word recklessly to the bill would change
uh the enforcement significantly
our rangers currently look at all of the
parties involved in a timber harvest
when they're examining the evidence
to determine how the trespass occurred
so this the added language extends the
culpability to the landowner
if they were the causing effect of the
timber trespass
in other words if they provided
erroneous maps or
gave verbal instructions that clearly
were not
accurate
this allows the rangers to
move that investigation towards the
landowner but they would do that under
the current law anyway
this this refinement of the language
just formally extends that culpability
to the landowner if
if the
okay can we uh anybody any have anybody
have any questions for
exactly
uh
anybody on the
up there no questions
uh thank you very much
uh is there anyone
that's it
uh from the depart division of forests
and his testimony is
is there anyone else
in the audience who would like to
participate
with their hands up
there's no one with their hands up then
i will declare
the
now
should
we are we
we got a
question on
a
an amendment
to the bill
uh
uh we
do we were do you wish to discuss that
uh
i could we can go into executive session
to discuss that
uh
or you know or or we can uh we can
simply uh
uh move this bill off uh in the to the
vernon for an additional
uh or for the the drafting of an
amendment
uh to be brought to the executive
session
uh and dispose of it there whether we
take the executive take the amendment or
not
uh
i'll
uh of
and that i don't want to
just be expedient
there's uh there's two hands up
oh there's two hands up
representative
representative harp
miss thank you mr chair uh just as
to address the issue of an amendment
and the comments of some of the other
speakers and presenters
a simpler way to amend it would be
simply to delete the for the or
on the first door where it says or carry
away if you just put comma carry away or
cause to be cut you're not repeating
either the negligent or the reckless but
yeah it was just as strict construction
with the calmer and or a second or
that's what concerned me so i don't
think we need to get involved if the
representatives willing to amend uh to
add another word again just delete the
first or in either uh section in both
sections and that would resolve that we
don't have to get involved with what
happens if you add another another word
reckless or negligence thank you thank
you mr jim
president
okay uh
representative cohen
are you and asked if we needed an
amendment or not and i was going to say
uh just as my opinion should ask her i'd
be fine with the bill as it is but i do
respect representative harb's expertise
and if he feels there's need for
um
okay no more hands no more hands are up
uh
if if there's going to be an amendment
i'm fine with uh going to ols
to request it and as to whether it's the
or
taken out or the negligently put in all
on what is uh
the best thing legislatively to do
all right
well we could then uh we do have uh
executive sessions scheduled for
any for
we could have an executive session on
any bill at any time if we wish
so
if an amendment can come
in uh at us at another time we can take
the exit take up
this this bill and executive session at
any time
uh and but i will
you know there won't be any surprises
everybody will know that we're going to
be doing it
so
we'll
for the executive set for
an amendment to come in and when it
comes in
we will uh
we'll go we will
we will have the executive session
uh
okay
all right
everybody uh
i don't know
that this is just
it's just uh you know this is not
part of the hearing this is just uh
doing this is just
housekeeping so
uh sorry so the this bill uh will it'll
be uh it'll be hell the executive
session on this bill will be held at us
okay
oh did i forget that yep i did i could
have to reopen the hearing anyway just
to get this into into the record the uh
okay i'm opening reopening the hearing
the
uh reading in
those who support or or those who
cut off these are all support of the
bill
bob gaida senator gaida
aaron hennessy
of the senate uh
senator hennessey
uh tom
pozchak zach
kozak
matt leahy
robert johnson ii
lobbyist with fine borough
leahy was the scientist society for the
protection of new hampshire forest
and jason stock you heard suzanne smith
you heard eric rathbun
member of the public
and eric sartel
okay
and i'll
close the hearing again
uh
we have the next hearing is
at
three o'clock
that that will be a
long one
and that one we will
just be here in hearing we will not be
entertaining any
uh
executive sessions
mr chairman
yes
uh you can take me off as a speaker i
did list to speak on that bill but in
the essence of time i can certainly make
my case an executive session on this
bill uh so i will not be speaking on the
bill
okay
rep representative gunski
has the three-page list
so
sure
patrick
good i
i still trying to figure out what
i don't i don't know how they're going
to amend it i'm not sure what they're
going to do whether it's going to be
adding
it said recklessly
and then he said negligently at the end
and then he said just remove or my
preference mr stock your microphone's
still on just to let you know okay
i heard people thrash trash in me when
the mic was on
i just remember
well what makes you so nice today
[Laughter]
considering all the technology that we
have going on here andy you're not doing
so you have 26 attendees
okay 20 artistic panelists
so you have 26 visitors okay 26 visitors
and 20 people
okay all right
there are we okay it's we got one or two
oh i don't know who they are
uh they could be listening
well they just if they speak if they
oh yeah
all right folks
yes
so
okay
open up the hearing on uh
house bill
611 fn
the prime sponsor is
uh representative cushman
uh
are you representative cushman
as
hi i'm here can you hear me
uh yes we can hear you
very good uh
all right the floor is yours
thank you thank you mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee
my name is leah cushman i'm a
representative for the towns of wear and
deering this is my first term as state
representative and i serve on the health
human services and elderly affairs
committee
a little background i'm a registered
nurse of six years i work in med-surg
rehab
long-term care and also home care and i
also have experience in case management
and wound care
i'm sponsoring this bill hb 611 which is
very similar to hb 192 from the
2019-2020 session
that bill passed out of committee with a
16-3 bipartisan ought to pass
recommendation and was placed on the
consent calendar when it came to the
floor the committee chair pulled it from
the consent calendar and tabled it and
it died on the table
i'm sponsoring this bill because as a
nurse informed consent is extremely
important to me and i believe that
public water fluoridation circumvents
true informed consent for individuals
municipalities must bring the issue to a
vote in the town before a policy of
water fluoridation is adopted but many
people don't have time to partake in
that process or are unaware that the
question is on the table
many people are unaware their tap water
is already fluoridated despite their
town website or newspaper publishing
that information
the reality is that most people don't
look
the last time that the question of
adding fluoride to drinking water was
brought to committee for a vote to
communities for a vote was in the year
in all the towns supplied by manchester
waterworks
fluoridation won by one percent in an
election that had very low turnout
essentially 15 000 people decided for
150 000 people
the dental lobby had spent tens of
thousands of dollars on ads and mailers
according to their own internal
documents and had a former us surgeon
general as their key spokesperson
that's what pushed them over the edge
for the close win there
while there is a demonstrated benefit
from the use of topical fluoride in
preventing dental decay
and limited demonstrated benefit from
ingesting fluoride and water
there is a substantial amount of
evidence that ingesting fluoride can be
extremely harmful especially to fetuses
infants and children in new hampshire in
2008 fluoride systems were installed in
some schools and after four years of
water fluoridation in these schools the
union leader reported that tooth decay
continued to rise
only after the state introduced dental
clinics in schools that provided
screenings cleanings and sealants to
decay rates decrease
as far as harm dental fluorosis is
internationally recognized as a visible
sign of systemic toxicity caused by
fluoride
it indicates improper mineralization
leading to staining and weakening of the
enamel
in 2014 the cdc reported that the rate
of dental fluorosis had increased over
400 percent from the rates found a
decade after the widespread start of
fluoridation in the 1950s
in 2019 the cdc published updated data
showing that 65 of adolescents now had
dental fluorosis
this was a 60 increase from the
fluorosis rates reported by the cdc when
the new hampshire legislature passed the
florida fluoridation warning bill into
law to protect infants
that bill required warnings to be sent
to residents of towns with fluoridated
water to not use it to reconstitute
infant formula
on a personal note my own son has severe
dental fluorosis from drinking
fluoridated tap water when we lived in
massachusetts i didn't even know our
water was fluoridated until his dentist
explained to me why he had staining on
his teeth
other studies have shown a relationship
between ingesting fluoridated water and
increased rates of add hypothyroidism
osteoporosis and neurological problems
including decreased iq
dosage for individuals is nearly
impossible to regulate as it is based on
intake the therapeutic window between
the lowest effective dose and toxic
level is very narrow in 2014 the upper
limit was reduced by 40 percent from 1.2
to 0.7 parts per million by the us
department of health and human services
after cdc data showed overexposure in
fluoridated communities
regardless of possible harm or benefit
water fluoridation is the only instance
in society in which medication is forced
on individuals by majority rule and now
in some cases without even requiring a
vote in 2019 a non-german amendment was
made to change the water fluoridation
law to allow towns receiving water from
towns and cities that floridate to only
notify residents prior to introducing
the water and no vote was needed
in conclusion
most toothpastes are fluoridated there
are fluoride mouth rinses
fluoride tablets are available and
therefore affordable
dentists routinely give fluoride
treatments at semi-annual visits
these are all ways to ensure adequate
fluoride supplementation with proper
informed consent
and with less risk less risk of
fluorotoxicity
those who do not want fluoridated water
in these fluoridated communities must
buy expensive filtration systems to
remove fluoride or else buy bottled
water that isn't fluoridated or seek out
spring water
they pay taxes for for water treatment
and then they receive water that they
can't use or don't want to use and then
on top of that they have to buy
filtration equipment or bottled water
the decision to have fluoride in water
should be an individual decision with
proper informed consent not a community
decision that's why this practice needs
to be abolished in new hampshire i think
i thank you mr chairman and members of
the committee for your time please
support hb 611 with a vote of ought to
pass
there any questions
representative gunski i have a question
representative this is representative
mike gunski
i think the um the
meeting room is muted i can't hear
anything
that has been happening during the day
today
all right you're good okay can you hear
me yes i can
we had a small technical issue sorry
uh representative i wanted to ask you
had have you taken some time to look at
the fiscal note on this bill
i have
could you comment on
on the second page of the fiscal note it
gives us some figures
there's five bullet points and it talks
with your medical background you could
probably answer better than i could i
is is the fluoride supplementation is
that something that's fairly common
because there this is a pretty
significant fiscal note that they're
showing here although it's mostly
assumptions so i was wondering if you
could give me some clarification and
your views on that
um
yeah i i see this as all assumption i
as far as i know
um
fluoride supplements are relatively
inexpensive
and because
water fluoridation is only minimally
impactful in in controlling and
decreasing tooth decay i don't really
see that
you know more ingestion is is warranted
topical treatments
have the most impact and i don't really
see that there's going to be such a need
for
thank you
any other questions from uh
from the committee yeah
okay
see no questions from more questions
from the committee
uh thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you
okay what's my next person
mike
sorry about that
karen craver
from uh
new hampshire dhhs okay
karen uh what's it craver
craver
department of health and human services
am i unmuted
okay
we hear you
great
good afternoon chairman renzolo and
members of the committee my name is
karen kraver i'm a chronic disease and
environmental epidemiologist with the
department of health and human services
within the division of public health
services
i support our state's oral health
program and i'm here today to speak in
opposition of this bill
the role of the division is to support
policies that promote evidence-based
public health practices such as
community water fluoridation
the practice has been recognized by the
centers for disease control and
prevention as one of the top 10 public
health achievements of the 20th century
after more than seven decades of
evidence major help in scientific
organizations continue to support the
practice as one that is safe and
effective
among the list of supporters are the cdc
the institute of medicine the national
academy of sciences the united states
public health service the world health
organization the american dental
association
the american medical association the
american water works association and the
new hampshire department of health and
human services
although fluoride containing products
and supplements contribute to the
prevention of tooth decay community
water fluoridation is believed to be the
most cost effective and beneficial
approach through every stage of life and
for all people regardless of age race
ethnicity or socioeconomic status
it's a strategy that reaches the most
vulnerable among us individuals who may
not have access to other preventive
services
it's a strategy that addresses and
reduces health disparities
the practice of water fluoridation
prevents tooth decay for children and
adults by an estimated 25 percent
data collected from fluoridated systems
in new hampshire show that the annual
cost of community water fluoridation
ranges from 27 cents to 3.05 cents per
person per year depending on the size of
the community
multiple studies have been conducted to
estimate the economic impact of
community water fluoridation
while methodology has varied results
have consistently pointed to
fluoridation as a health-based strategy
that results in cost savings for both
individuals and for communities
one such analysis showed a return on
investment of twenty dollars for every
dollar invested by communities and an
average savings of thirty two dollars
per person by avoiding the need for
treatment for dental decay
cost savings come not only from the
avoidance of direct cost of dental care
but also the indirect cost of missed
work or miss schooling due to dental
pain or for the receipt of dental care
at a time when state and local
governments are facing tremendous fiscal
pressure the public can feel confident
that community water fluoridation is one
example of a program that truly saves
money
to date there has been no sound
scientific evidence showing optimized
fluoridation as a cause of adverse
health effects for systemic disorders
this was true even in the past when the
recommendation included levels exceeding
today's standard
in accordance with the guidelines
established by the community preventive
services task force in 2013 the cdc
updated the fluoridation recommendation
to establish 0.7 milligrams of fluoride
per liter of drinking water as the
optimum concentration needed to achieve
dental benefit to ensure compliance with
this recommendation public water systems
that practice fluoridation are required
to test fluoride content on a daily
basis and to report the data to the
department of environmental services on
a monthly basis
this data is monitored by both the
department of environmental services and
the division of public health services
and is reported to the cdc
according to the united states
environmental protection agency
health-related health-related risks
associated with fluoride become a
concern when fluoride in drinking water
reaches a level greater than 5.7 times
of that recommended level
given the close monitoring that occurs
with fluoridation we can be assured that
this has not happened and will not
happen in our communities
the policy proposed in this house bill
house bill 611 is in opposition to seven
decades of scientific evidence
demonstrate demonstrating both safety
and health benefits of community water
fluoridation at recommended or optimized
levels for this reason the department of
health and human services opposes the
bill
thank you is there any questions
uh thank you mr chairman um
my question would be um who provides the
fluoride
uh to the state that's um put into our
i'm gonna ask if there's someone from
department of environmental services who
might be able to speak to that um it i
don't believe it's centralized i think
water systems purchase their supplies um
from different vendors
uh follow-up question mr chairman uh for
a follow-up
uh do you know if the public health
regions or dhhs provides um
education or partners with local
dentists to educate their patients
regarding fluoride and that they're
drinking their water
so we do work with the dental community
to offer trainings on water fluoridation
and also with with water systems provide
training to drinking water operators on
fluoridation
and we partner we've partnered in the
past with our oral health coalition um
our dental society and also with our
department of environmental services on
those trainings
uh follow-up question mr chairman
or follow-up
are those trainings designed directly to
the patients in the
um so trainings that i have participated
in have been for
for health providers public health
professionals
and also members of the the drinking
water community but we do um
we do provide education to the community
as well not necessarily in the form of
trainings but through educational
materials and we're available to respond
one last follow-up question mr sherman
up
where would uh members of the community
access materials uh
other than you know online at the dhh
website if they want to learn more about
what's in their drinking water
if people wanted to learn specifically
about what's in their drinking water um
i mean drinking water systems put out
consumer confidence reports which
includes details about about this the
water and the specific system if people
want to learn more about community water
fluoridation there are some great sites
including one put out by the american
academy academy of pediatrics called
ilikemyteeth.org
and we could certainly direct people to
a number of different resources
thank you
uh okay uh
representative
sorry was that for me yes representative
kelly for a question
yes ms craver uh we heard previous
testimony that there was little evidence
of uh ingestible fluorite fluoride
having an effect
um
having a a health benefit so there i
mean there are there are benefits both
topically and systemically and so that's
why we support community water
fluoridation which actually acts in both
ways you know there's the ingestion of
fluoride but also the contact with
people's teeth throughout the day as
they drink water and both are beneficial
okay
uh any uh other question uh it's uh
representative gunski good question
thank you mr chair
uh miss craper
what does your department or how does
your department identify the additive in
the water that fluoride attitude is do
you consider that a medicine what do you
i'm not sure i'm understanding the
question i mean it's it's a
we recognize it as a public health
practice to
to add fluoride to drinking water
okay
so
so it's just that you you consider it
it's part of the water treatment process
that provides a health benefit
okay
any other questions
representative craig
uh yes ma'am uh miss kramer just
we just heard testimony um that
fluoride was directly attributable to
abd hyperthyroidism
lower iq
and other issues
how would you respond to those
assertions
that were just made in this hearing
i would stand by the statement in my
testimony that there hasn't been sound
scientific evidence supporting those
findings
any other questions by members of the
committee
i have a question uh do you
you've uh find uh
no no scientific background
scientific basis
um so at the at the level for
optimization 0.7 milligrams per liter i
would not expect to see fluorosis at
you know possibly at higher levels
but community water fluoridation the
practice of community water fluoridation
is closely monitored
so that water systems are achieving that
optimized level
and and i would say you know the the
environmental protection agency that
sets a
max contaminant level at which there may
be health effects which i said is 5.7
times higher or more than 5.7 times
higher than that optimization level
in the the secondary max contaminant
level which is set for some constituents
including fluoride where there may be an
impact on odor taste color and in the
case of fluoride potential um cosmetic
impacts is two two milligrams per liter
so again the level for optimization is
0.7 milligrams per liter
and that is a target that is achieved by
any other questions by members of the
committee
uh yes thank you
are you aware of areas in the state of
new hampshire where the natural ground
water may have higher levels of fluoride
than is what is allowed in our uh
regular drinking water public drinking
water systems
that's a question that i would differ
to our partners from the department of
environmental services to speak to
is fluoride naturally occurring in the
groundwater
yes yes fluoride is naturally occurring
in the groundwater
did i see representative gold wave or
yes
yes uh
the answer that you gave to uh
chairman renzolo's question
was a little more scientific that i
could understand do you think you could
put it in more layman's term for me
can can you remind me which question
that was sorry
you'll have to repeat it i think about
fluorosis
oh about the levels at which you might
expect to see fluorosis
so
so just just to very broadly summarize i
would not expect to see um fluorosis at
the levels of fluoride
um which you would see with community
water fluoridation so where water
systems are actively partic uh
fluoridating their water
you um
the
environmental protection agency has said
that you may see fluorosis at two
milligrams per liter which is more than
twice the level that water systems
fluoridate at
um
and as someone pointed out before
fluorite is naturally occurring in the
ground water and you and you could see
that naturally occurring fluoride in
your own home well or
um
in a small system served by a well but
you would not see levels like that
with community water fluoridation
that helpful
okay follow-up
sure
okay well does fluorescence occur in uh
the rest of the state and all the uh
little towns in new hampshire earth
i've been i mean i it's not something
that has been reported to me in my six
years with the
was that that's your quest that uh
your answer to your question the
gold
thank you that's fine thank you
thanks
representative for the first time
thank you
i have a question about why it is that
so that's
canada seems to be
banning florida fluoridation of public
waters
when
i
um i mean i'm not positioned to speak
about decisions being made by other
government agencies
i can speak to our own agency's support
of the practice of water fluoridation
for the reasons stated in my testimony
but i wouldn't want to
want to guess as to why other
governments are making different
decisions
thank you
uh
representative moran for the first time
thank you uh can you describe to me or
provide an example
of any other
mineral
additive
supplement or drug
that is provided to the community in
um
i mean i'm just trying i'm trying to
think you know my my scope at the health
department is is narrowly to support the
oral health program
i appreciate that
i can understand that mr chairman can i
regards to the dental oral health uh is
there a benefit for adults in new
hampshire for dental services uh who for
medicaid
sorry i'm not sure understanding your
question and it may be that our medicaid
dental director will be speaking later
she may be more poised to answer this
question uh water fluoridation does
benefit both children and adults
yeah um my i guess my question would be
um
if
our clarification yeah can i ask a
clarification clarifying question
sure
so
uh mr chairman is that all right
yes
so i understand that in new hampshire
children have a dental benefit for if
when they are low income and qualified
for medicaid
and i understand that fluoride
can be beneficial for
healthy teeth
my question is
for low-income individuals throughout
the state of new hampshire
um
who are in adults do they have access to
a medicaid benefit
so they can access fluoride treatments
the medi i'll let the our medicaid
dental director speak to this when when
she speaks um later if we can bookmark
this question but it's my understanding
that the
dental program for adults in new
hampshire through medicaid is limited
to emergency services
thank you
uh okay representative
yep represent representative gunski
representative gunski then
representative followed by
representative post
thank you mr chair
i just wanted to ask another question on
how do we determine the amount of
fluoride an individual takes in to their
body when consumption is very different
between individuals and has the state
taking that into consideration
well this the cdc set the standards
based on that data and it
i stated in my testimony there and i
think someone else stated previously
there used to be a range of for
optimization
um
in in the
based on based on the research based on
the practice of fluoridation they've
determined that 0.7 milligrams per liter
is
is a safe amount um based on the the
amount of water that people drink in
various places throughout the country
you know which you know can vary based
on climate and activity level and that
do you know what uh amount
of water that was used to determine that
i do not know i would have to follow up
on that
i believe the average
that i've seen for a male is 3.7 liters
and a female is 2.7 those are the
figures that i have found i just would
maybe
clarify that or if you could provide
additional information on that would be
wonderful okay i can take that back to
my agency and follow up on that
thank you thank you
uh
yes thank you for taking uh my question
um i just wanted to ask miss uh
uh craber
if she's done any research on the
adverse effects of fluoride in children
and adults
so i've you know i've read through the
various studies and the various findings
and again stand by my testimony about
that
does that uh
answer your question representative post
that's fine thank you
is there any other representatives who
representative mayville
thank you thank you mr chair for taking
my question this is a question from ms
craver
i noted that the american health
rankings throughout the united states
showed new hampshire is number 44 out of
50 for many many years related to the
fluoridation of our water supply right
down there with louisiana dc and new
jersey i'm wondering what your agency
has done to increase public awareness of
the benefit of fluoridation in water as
someone who doesn't seem to have a
have skin in the game other than this
being a public health
um
you know assistance
and that's really interesting to
understand that you know
why why we rank so low
um so you're you're correct we do rank
we do rank low in the nation um in the
in those rankings are based on the
proportion of the residents served by
community water systems who receive
fluoridated water um
and so it's not even it's it's taking
it's not even taking into account the
people who are on private well so it's
looking just at those server public
water systems and we have one of the
lowest proportions in the country served
by um fluoridated systems and you know
what we're continuing to do through work
with the oral health program is to
provide education on the health benefits
of fluoridation the safety of
fluoridation and also how it can save
money as a practice
and you're right we don't have skin in
the game other than inferring the health
of new hampshire residents and that is
we would like to see new hampshire be
higher in those rankings that is a goal
any other
i'm just asking any other
representatives
seeing none
thank you very much for your testimony
chair calls stuart cooper
stewart
are you there mr cooper i don't see him
here he's a representative uh no
no he's a uh part of the audience
american environment
yeah
yeah just say uh tell me again uh
say to say out loud is who he represents
for the record representing uh
shows here the uh american environmental
health studies project
okay mr cooper
yes yes i am i'm here can you hear me
the floor is yours
well thank you very much
uh
thank you for the opportunity to speak
in favor of this important legislation
my name is stuart cooper i'm a resident
of sutton new hampshire and i'm speaking
today as a concerned citizen a parent
and as the campaign director for the
american environmental health studies
project and their fluoride action
network campaign our non-profit includes
more than 5 500 medical and scientific
professionals opposed to the addition of
fluoridation chemicals to the drinking
water and we urge the committee to
recommend hb 611 as all to pass just as
you did in 2019 with a bipartisan 16-3
vote this will ensure the state's
drinking water remains safe for all
citizens including bottle-fed infants
the developing fetus residents who are
hypersensitive to fluoride and residents
with thyroid liver and kidney impairment
i'd like to alert you to three important
emails sent to each of you over the past
several days and the first is under the
title fluoridation deposition videos and
this includes three short videos
featuring our attorney for our federal
lawsuit against epa introducing and
showing several clips from deposition
deposition videos of representatives
under oath speaking on behalf of the cdc
and epa acknowledging under threat of
perjury they cannot actually verify the
safety or effectiveness of water
fluoridation for the fetus or bottle fed
infants what you've just heard from the
nh dhhs person was just talking points
from the american dental association you
heard a lobbying presentation
the first clip you will see is from
casey hannon the oral health director of
the cdc who confirms there is absolutely
no benefit whatsoever of flow from
fluoride to the fetus or to bottle fed
infants they have no teeth there's no
benefit meanwhile you see a second video
where he says the cdc has zero no
studies or data showing uh safety
regarding fluoride and the brain
meanwhile there are now over 66 human
peer-reviewed published studies showing
that fluoride is a neurotoxin so when we
just heard there's no scientific
evidence showing harm that you you know
you should ask why haven't you found it
because it was published in jama
pediatrics only the most credible
pediatric journal in the united states
it was published in the lancet the
oldest medical journal in the world it
was published in the journal of
pediatrics i mean
this is absurd just look for it i mean
you're hearing talking points the third
deposition video is from dr joyce
donahue from the office of drinking
water at the epa who says based on the
new science over the past several years
the epa's current fluoride regulations
are not safe so under oath you get a
totally different message than you do on
talking points
when you realize okay so i'll just move
on just for the sake of time the second
email you received was under the title
fluoridation studies showing harm there
is now a large body of government funded
nih or cdc funded research indicating so
i mean i guess they don't find that
credible i don't know indicating that
fluoride is neurotoxic is associated
with lowered iq in children and a
significant increase in adhd diagnosis
uh the experts in toxicology have
likened the size of the effect to that
from lead including bruce lamphier who
was the person the scientists in the 80s
and 90s that caused
raise the alarms about low levels of
lead exposure that works for the boston
children to our apartment uh
that's someone else but that's bollinger
but so it's now they're not comparing it
to the size of lead
we invite you to read these studies
yourself don't trust me i sent you the
studies the links to pubmed read them
the people on the other side are going
to tell you don't read the studies trust
us listen to our endorsements these
unscientific endorsements none of which
they're all decades old none of which
you know have been taken since these
studies have come out these endorsements
are meaningless most of these studies
have come out since 2017 decades after
these endorsements were first
acknowledged
this committee has a rich history of
taking action to protect new hampshire
citizens from fluoridation in 2012 when
the centers for disease control reported
that 41 percent of our teenagers now had
dental fluorosis a permanent
discoloration and weakening of the
enamel caused by
systemic or swallowing fluoride prior to
eight years of age 41
this committee and the legislature
passed hb 1416 making it law in florida
communities to warn parents not to
reconstitute infant formula with
fluoridated tap water so already we
acknowledge we shouldn't be giving this
to infants we're still going to put it
in the water
so that that action was prophetic
because two years later the u.s
department of health and human services
lowered the recommended level of
fluoride in the water by 40 percent
because of this overexposure so the same
people on the other side now they're
telling you safe and effective read the
talking point safe and effective we're
saying the same thing there for a level
of 1.2 before they were forced to lower
it so i mean listen who's been right so
now in 2019 the cdc published updated
data showing that number went from 41
to now 65 percent of adolescents have
dental fluorosis it's only going up
this committee heard testimony in 2019
about new studies the first was bashes
showing that low levels of fluoride this
was nih funded national institutes of
health funded low levels of fluoride
caused a five to seven point iq loss
there was other studies that confirmed
that we heard from
peckham that there was a 62 percent
increase in hypothyroidism diagnosis in
optimally fluoridated communities of 0.7
and i could keep going on there's
there's more
higher levels in bashash 2018 and
environmental international higher
levels of fluoride exposure during
pregnancy were associated with global
measures of adhd and more symptoms so
now two years later what has happened
since you guys voted sixteen to three on
that last bill what has happened you
were proven right
six new studies funded by nih or cdc
using cdc data have confirmed that of
these effects the first was published in
last year in the journal of
american medical association's journal
pediatrics talk about credible
journal pediatrics and it showed that
children in canadian optimally
fluoridated communities had an average
of five to seven points lower iq
because their mothers were exposed
during uh while the fetus was developing
they're exposed to just optimally
fluoridated water rydell found this one
was published in the leading toxicology
journal environmental international
found a shocking 284
increase in the prevalence of adhd among
children in fluoridated communities the
list goes on there there are now seven
mother offspring studies most of which
funded by nih showing that women during
the fetal development or bottle-fed
infants uh who's all who's all their
nutrition nutrition all their meals are
re being used with reconstituted florida
tap water have lowered iq and increased
adhd rates i've sent you the studies
don't trust me read them the other side
doesn't want you to read them now the
new hampshire legislature has proven
willing to act before federal agencies
on protecting citizens from toxins you
banned mtbe from gasoline bpa from
infant bottles and created the most
protective standards on pfoas despite
inaction by the epa and cdc and the us
department of health and human services
let me tell you when they lowered the
fluoride levels in 2014
that was after the national research
council in 2006
told them those levels weren't safe and
that chill infants were being
overexposed it took them what's that
eight years to actually implement those
actions are we gonna wait now and let
thousands more uh citizens just be
harmed while we wait for federal action
and let me point out something we talk
about lack of credibility or
just a month ago the former director of
the national institute of environmental
health sciences that's nih and the
national toxicology program of the
national institutes of health her name
is linda bernbaum
former ntp director the lead the
most renowned toxicologist in the world
wrote an op-ed that was published in
environmental health news titled it's
time to protect our kids developing
brains from fluoride and she talks about
ending fluoridation because of all of
these studies she's not alone
the the jama pediatrics
editor a physician from seattle said
quote he would not want his wife
drinking fluoridate water if she were
pregnant the co-host the editor of the
entire jama journal network also
physician said the same thing and raised
the important issue of how low-income
women could avoid fluoride while
pregnant they can't
um the 2020 study shown that bottle-fed
infants were overexposed and lowered
their iq of fluoridated water optimally
lower their iq this was again
republished in the journal pediatrics
just last year in their column of
current best evidence translating best
evidence in the best care
so please read those studies i sent
even leading neuroscientist david
bellinger of the boston children's
hospital and harvard
uh included fluoride in a list of
chemicals known or suspected to
interfere with neurodevelopment of
children
so
and i'll just finish off i know thank
you very much for letting me go on i'll
finish off with one last point because
it was raised last about how new
hampshire is ranked 44 in fluoridated
water
that's true we are we're very low in
fluoridated water but the proponents
don't want to tell you is that new
hampshire children have the third lowest
rate of dental decay in the nation
we're the one of the least fluoridated
states we have the third lowest rate of
dental decay in the nation vermont which
has uh which is
ranked 39 for fluoridation so also low
is second lowest rate of dental decay in
the nation
so we don't need this unnecessary
chemical in our water supply to treat
people um and let's look at the three
most fluoridated communities now and
kentucky 99 fluoridated
they have a rate that's double their
third grade dental decay rate is 60
percent that's double new hampshire's
rate of uh 34
minnesota 98 fluoridated the rate of
decay is 54 compared to our 34. illinois
98.5 fluoridated their rate of decay is
52.4
that's that's that's
so
listen i've sent you the science i've
sent you all of these these these
articles and journal articles from the
leading toxicologist this is a really
simple solution um you know we can fix
that we can fix decay but you can't fix
someone's brain after it's been damaged
let's take action let's protect our
children read the studies don't trust me
but read the studies and ask those
people that are now advocating this ask
them say what are the fluorescence rates
in new hampshire because they don't have
an answer to that
all we know is at the federal level they
mr cooper
yeah i guess you turn them back on
yes i'm sorry
mr cooper
uh yes
uh you know i've let you go for a long
time for a fairly long
uh time
uh i tried to get
uh
the beginning and you know the the first
of pros and cons out
uh for both
on both sides so i let folks go
uh
but i i think it's time we moved on if
you can uh
wrap up
oh yes i'm done i've spent over a decade
studying this issue so if anybody has
any questions uh feel free to ask i
could answer just about all the ones
people previously asked but thank you
for indulging me uh any questions uh
from the representatives for um mr
cooper
anyone uh
none from the panel all right thank you
very much mr cooper thank you
okay uh
who is the next next we have brandon
kernan with the new hampshire department
of environmental services okay speaking
in opposition to the deal all right mr
curtin
i'm going to time people now
thank you jeremy can you hear me
yeah you're a little uh
back away from the mic please
okay i apologize my vpn just crashed
right as you call it on me of course um
my name is brandon kernan i'm the
administrator
for how long do you wish to speak
about 60 seconds
okay
the floor is yours
thank you
i'm brandon kernan i'm the administrator
of the drinking water and groundwater
bureau
um thank you for the opportunity to
testify today the department opposes
this bill
we support fluoridation consistent with
recommendations of cdc to prevent tooth
decay
most of my points were covered by ms
craver earlier
you know there's a process to allow and
abolish at the local level fluoridation
so communities have control over this
process at the primary water system
level
and also when there is fluoridation
there are rules in place and processes
in place to ensure the design and the
operations of the fluoridation process
meets regulatory requirements and that
the appropriate levels of fluoride are
maintained and there's safety measures
involved to protect from overfeeding
and we also require operators with
higher certification levels oversee the
pro process
as far as the chemicals used they have
to be certified by the national
sanitation foundation um our drinking
water rules address um where uh what
type of chemicals you have
fluoride or other treatment chemicals um
where they can come from and what
certifications they require for drinking
water
and i'll just end by pointing out that
our toxicologist dr john alley
is also signed into this meeting
should you have more questions about
and that's it thank you
uh thank you thank you very much any
uh
this
is
representative creighton
i asked the same question
you just heard the
testimony of mr cooper
in claiming
all sorts of medical issues
several times now
uh
our agency
first we have our toxicologist that
tracks the science and looks for
scientific research that has achieved
consensus across the experts and then we
also collaborate with other drinking
water programs at the national level to
share information
and at this point we have agreed with
the position that epa in the cdc has
taken on fluoridation
that being said we continue to review
the information for this chemical and
other chemicals that might be in
drinking water and revised policies
thank you sir
oh representative moran for a question
yes thank you mr chairman um
maybe i missed it um can did you offer
it's bought from companies that have
achieved national sanitation foundation
certification and so i could i could
provide you a list of companies that
typically provide drinking water
chemicals such as the chemicals used to
fluoridate
i don't have that in front of me right
now but that's something that you can
certainly follow up with
yeah if that would be great thank you
representative gold
yes i have a question uh
chairman um
the uh this uh
the des is mainly just concerned about
the uh technical aspects of uh
fluoride they do they go into the uh
you know what happens to people if they
have fluoride or anything or is it are
you just concerned about how it's put
into the water and
we're concerned about all of our
drinking water standards and guidelines
to ensure they're protective of public
health and
you continue to look at the best
available science and so
oh no we don't turn a blind eye to
other information about about our
standards um so and we also have a
toxicologist that reviews our standards
and guidelines and as science emerges
they can change our guidelines and
standards can change over time as
warranted
thank you
um
i wanted to ask um mr kiernan have you
ever done any research
no i have not researched it we rely upon
research agencies and
federal agencies to complete that work
and the health and health agencies as
well but our bureau has not conducted a
research study
so
was that a yes yes oh yeah thank thank
you um so mr kiernan the information
you're providing us is is that from
talking points or is that from something
um
you you know to be true by doing
research
well
akin to research we have 60 years of
experience of communities adding
fluoride and to the extent data becomes
available
a state agency
in whatever form it's been over the time
would have reacted to it but there's
certainly um research that i guess we
are part of that effect is we're relying
on federal agencies and we are part of
the federal government that do conduct
the studies that do have the capability
in the research scientists to keep the
look over the studies
and so yeah i mean that's part of that's
part of the system we are cdc as well i
mean they represent us so you know it's
okay
is that any more question any other
questions
thank you very much for your testimony
next
next we have sarah
penn for spam i believe with the new
hampshire
chess division of medicaid services
and speaking in opposition to the goal
sarah ben
uh it's hi yes i'm dr sarah finney
i'm sorry
it's it's pronounced finney
did you back up from the mic a little
bit
um
is this better
uh yes
it is okay
um
good afternoon uh chairman renzolo and
members of the committee i appreciate
your time this afternoon
as i already stated my name is dr sarah
finney i am the medicaid dental director
i am i am here to express my opposition
on behalf of the department to hb 611
the new hampshire department of health
and human services division of medicaid
services has functional responsibility
for the medicaid program as well as
health planning reporting data and
research
the division of medicaid services police
policy decisions are based on scientific
evidence and best practices
and for the reasons which i'm about to
share
they are the reasons that we oppose this
bill
in the past the new hampshire
legislature has seen fit to put in place
a number of rsas which frame the process
by which a community community can
determine whether or not they wish to
fluoridate their water supply or
continue that fluoridation
and bills similar to this bill have been
deemed inexpedient to legislate
as the dental director for the division
of medicaid services i am concerned
about the potential negative impact on
the overall health and quality of life
of children covered by new hampshire
medicaid as well as other children and
adults that live in the areas that have
community water fluoridation
children who are
covered by medicaid are at high risk for
dental disease
and research has shown that there will
be an increase in dental disease
affected teeth when water systems are
defluoridated
the highest cost for that defluoridation
will be for dental treatment for
children who are born after the
community water fluoridation is ceased
so while we may see some increases
initially in the costs in medicaid they
will
continue to go up as we get farther
along in the lifespan of children who
have not had the benefits of community
water fluoridation
additionally currently
school-based dental programs are not in
operation due to the pandemic and the
ongoing situation of remote and hybrid
learning in schools there are a number
of children who receive their preventive
dental care in these settings and
they're already being impacted by the
fact that those programs are not
operating at this time and the loss of
fluorinated water would add another
impact another negative impact for them
and this is also holding true for adults
in these areas
it is harder for adults to get in for
dental care right now
dental practices have been at a reduced
capacity due to the pandemic and so
there is a similar effect for adults
because
the adults do have a benefit a topical
benefit from fluoride on their teeth so
community water fluoridation is not just
for children
under current recommendations systemic
fluoride is considered best practice
and for tooth decay prevention in
children from birth to 12 years of age
administration of fluoride during this
age range prevents future dental disease
because the fluoride is built into
the structure of the tooth as opposed to
just
attaching on the surface
administration of fluoride during this
time prevents future dental disease and
also provides the topical benefit that i
have already described and
remineralization of a tooth where tooth
decay begins
in people of all ages
while it is impossible for the division
of medicaid services to precisely
calculate the increase in medicaid
spending that would occur in a given
year as a result of defluoridation of
community water systems
we could provide
a calculation of
an increase of 13 and a half percent of
dental disease
in the medicaid population and and
factor that over
what is considered to be our dental
expenditures for state fiscal year 2022
and that estimated increase cost would
be approximately 1.5 million dollars and
that would continue to increase with
time as i mentioned earlier
as we get farther out with more children
having less effect from the community
water fluoridation
in the fiscal note we also provided an
estimate of what
the cost would be to provide fluoride
supplements for medicaid
children covered by medicaid
and
expenditures would also increase
for increased use of emergency
department visits by children who may
it is for all of the reasons that i have
spoken of which opposes and and they um
this bill
opposes decades of research and evidence
that support the safe and effective
use of optimally fluoridated water to
improve oral health and therefore
overall health of children and adults in
these communities
so for these reasons the department has
chosen to oppose this legislation
and i thank you for your time this
afternoon and i'm happy to answer
questions
yeah thank you for your testimony uh is
there any question
uh representative marianne for a
question
uh thank you mr chairman uh thank you
doctor so much for being here um
would could you tell me um
about the dental benefits for adults in
new hampshire would they receive routine
care or fluoride in treatment for dental
care
under the current medicaid benefits
at this time the adult medicaid dental
benefit only covers emergency services
so those patie the adults
are eligible to have exams x-rays and
diagnosis of pain and infection
and then the only treatment for that
is extractions it's a very limited
benefit
we are currently working um towards
bringing in a more robust adult dental
benefit in fact there are two bills
going through the legislature this
session
and we have a prior bill from 2019 that
was signed into law where we are
planning for a more comprehensive adult
benefit but currently the adult benefit
mr chairman can i have a follow-up
please follow up
uh doctor um would you say that removing
the fluoride from the water would
disadvantage
impact disadvantage
in low-income
residents of new hampshire
absolutely
the as as karen kraver said earlier
the mission of the department of health
and human services is to help all the
citizens of the state but especially
those who are at a disadvantage
and community water fluoridation cuts
across all
educational socioeconomic
and ethnic
divisions among amongst our citizens in
this state and and provides a broad
uh mr chairman uh follow-up question
and i i believe that my constituents
would want me to ask these questions all
right for the follow up
uh doctor can you explain to me if there
is any other supplement medication
or vitamin or mineral that is um
given to um residents in drinking water
or any other manner in a public health
setting
other than that to my
all right i really can't speak for any
other state than new hampshire
but medications are not delivered
through water systems and we need to
remember that fluoride is a naturally
occurring mineral
so i i
i want to make that distinction very
clear
thank you so much doctor
thank you
any other
representatives to speak
oh yeah right now okay
well it's all set mr representative
kelly
okay
all right thank you very much for your
testimony
and thank you very much for your time
this afternoon
uh
next
next we have jennifer
pedone
um
[Music]
still unmuted
yeah the last one sarah fine yeah there
we go i could hear her typing in the
background
she's up and unmuted and jennifer
sorry but there's nothing we can do we
have to go on
uh
she's
uh next
yeah
yeah let's next christine arsenal
new hampshire aap member of the public
hi hello
um good afternoon my name is christine r
snow
i am a pediatrician in concord new
hampshire and the vice president of the
new hampshire chapter of the american
academy of pediatrics
i am here to speak in opposition of
i want to first talk a little bit about
dental caries so
dental caries as we know
commonly called cavities are an
infectious disease
wherein um bacteria present on a
person's teeth
metabolize carbohydrates forming an acid
and eroding tooth enamel
these cavities can progress through the
tooth leading to
tremendous pain
tooth loss
systemic infections
in additional from a social perspective
missed school and work
and are the single a child's
dental caries are the single greatest
risk for that child going on to develop
dental caries in adulthood
additionally from a personal standpoint
many of my patients
have had to have these dental caries
repaired which is a
procedure that is generally done under
general anesthesia which is
both stressful for families and not
without
risk
fluoride
is a very well studied
treatment to prevent
dental caries by
promoting the mineralization of tooth
enamel
it works as mentioned previously by both
topical and systemic roots
community water fluoridation is
an extremely
effective method of
reducing rates of dental caries
and
as previously mentioned this practice
has been done since the 1940s all over
the country
and research shows that it reduces rates
of dental caries in a community by 25
percent
the american academy of pediatrics put
out a
clinical policy statement in december
2020 renewing its standpoint inc in
support of
um the use of fluoride to prevent dental
caries and noted in this report that
there are over 3 000 studies
looking at the impact of fluoride and
fluoridation
on various health health outcomes
the only adverse event that has been
mentioned in
scientifically validated studies is this
risk
of dental fluorosis which is a purely
cosmetic outcome
leading to some whitish lines on the
teeth i don't mean to minimize that but
it does not
cause
nearly the same health burden as
dental caries itself which can lead to
systemic infections and in some cases
even death
as uh karen craver noted
community water fluoridation is one of
the cdc's top public health achievements
of the 20th century up there with
vaccination as a very successful
effective and safe public health effort
in conclusion
i and the members of the new hampshire
chapter of the aap
assert that
community water fluoridation is a safe
effective and extremely important public
health effort and it would be a mistake
to abolish it
any questions from the
representatives
uh representative penny j
yes
all right
thank you thank you mr chairman and
thank you everybody because i was
sitting in those seats yesterday all day
and you're probably hoping i'll be quick
so i will
um
i really support this bill and i thought
nothing i say is going to be anywhere as
impressive as what stuart cooper said
where he cited study after study by the
cdc and by the nih it's recent
more recent than you know the 40 years
they've been doing this or longer that
show that they are now measuring dangers
um and it's not just children that are
affected the people for whom fluoride is
absolutely
poisonous are the ones
on
on a kidney dialysis
i i used to drive a person to dialysis
as a volunteer and i was reading the
signs on the wall you should see the
long list of just foods they are
supposed to avoid because they have
fluoride
in them
so imagine how terrible it is for them
to be exposed just in drinking water
from our testimony today we've already
heard that it's far more effective
excuse me
it's far more effective to treat teeth
with a topical
uh treatment when people when kids go or
adults go to have their teeth clean it's
much more effective and the other uh
statistics that show that fluoridation
in water does not prevent kids from
getting dental caries is the study
comparing new hampshire to minnesota
if minnesota has 90 percent 98
fluoridation
and yet their dental caries rate is far
higher than ours
i think that's pretty good proof
that it's not a guarantee that you're
going to save kids by giving them
fluoridated water the other concern is
you know i you probably heard from me
about
vitamin d3 being protective and many
times people have said to me oh you want
to be careful you don't get too much
well i tell them to go do their own
research you know to get an idea what's
too much but look at this if you're
drinking water and fluorides in it
how do you even have any idea
what your dosage is
especially for little kids you know
because they're much more sensitive than
adults because of their weight
it takes a lot less to be
damaging to them
so i think um it's important to remember
too that it's extremely difficult to
remove fluoride from water that's why
the people who are on
dialysis
are really up a creek because the
dialysis itself cannot remove fluoride
it's just too tiny an ion it is a little
bitty chemical ion
now i may have already covered
everything i'm checking to make sure
um
yeah i don't think we're going to
increase dental expenses for medicaid at
all
we should be saving money by not having
to buy the fluoride to go in the water
so thank you very much for your
attention
and i hope that you consider that the
most recent science
is going to take a while to be adopted
by the cdc and the nih even though they
do the studies we all know
how grindingly slow governmental
agencies can act
representative bale for a question
representative gay
yes
uh representative bale
yes um thank you mr chairman um thank
you representative gay
i just wanted to ask if you know someone
with fluorosis
um
right now i'm not sure how extensive
that is that the colored teeth or does
that ex uh
does that extend to all the damage that
these people like who on kidney dialysis
have they have bone problems too it can
thank you so much representative gay
no
i did put on lipstick
all right i'm uh
i can't quite hear what's
right
where are we at
here brown is next gail brown is the
next speaker
okay
uh
yes are you able to hear me
how long do you plan to speak
i will be speaking two to three minutes
thank you
thank you um my name is gail brown and
first of all i am not a scientist nor
i'm going to attempt to be one or to
interpret science for you here today and
i also put on my lipstick um so what i
want to tell you is i am the director at
the new hampshire oral health coalition
and the coalition has been pulling
together oral health
stakeholders in new hampshire since 2002
our membership includes
many folks who do have a science
background they include folks from the
medical society from the nurse
practitioner association from northeast
delta dental department of health and
human services um the
dental allied training program at the
tech the pediatric society i was
thrilled to hear dr asano speaking
by state primary care so we are
we are large and we are
we are very committed to oral health
um what i would like to tell you today
is that for many of those members they
are part of national affiliates so our
pediatric society is part of the
american pediatric society the same with
the medical society the dental society
and we rely on those organizations and
programs as well as the centers for
disease control and prevention to
interpret our science and to provide us
with the platform that we can move
forward to improve
public health
so
i want to say to you that first and
foremost we support community water
fluoridation we have for years we we
support a coordinated and really
integrated fluoride program that helps
people to
be able to access both the systemic and
the topical
um use of fluoride that's the most
scientific thing i'm going to say to you
today i do want to point out a couple of
things dr arsenau spoke on behalf of
children she talked about the importance
because tooth decay is a progressive
infectious disease caused by bacteria it
destroys teeth it impacts oral health
but i want to say that is the same for
adults as it is for children and is
especially a problem for our senior
citizens who in are in nursing home
settings and for those of you who are
just thinking about us talking about
bacteria yes
humans spread dental bacteria person to
person to person okay
so the it's important that we
employ as many methods as we can
untreated decay and dental disease can
cause and if you've ever had dental pain
you know why i'm using the word intense
intense pain swelling broken teeth
inflamed and bleeding gums this is why
water fluoridation matters it can cause
difficulty chewing and digesting impair
people's speech and yes it can lead to
death through infection
it causes um very high medical treatment
costs as well as dental costs you see
people in the emergency room the
operating room and hospital inpatient
charges some of you have heard me say if
you're not managing dental disease
you're not managing health care and
you're not managing it its costs
so um i
with um
my colleagues who have said to you we
have 60 to 70 70 plus years of of
scientific information
we are sticking to the platforms not of
an individual physician or an individual
nurse or an individual scientist we are
sticking with the platforms that are
being put forward by their professional
associations the american medical
association the american academy of
pediatrics sorry my phone's ringing i
must round somebody up
the community water fluoride is easily
adjusted it is low cost dr finney told
you it would increase she is a dentist
this is her job it would increase
expenses here in the state
at the local level and also at the
county level remember i talked about
care in nursing homes so my final
statement is simply
that in addition to all of this this
legislation proposes a state mandate to
overrule local voter controlled
decisions about their own water supply
that did not go far in previous
legislation it's a very important point
and we haven't addressed it yet today
new hampshire residents take great pride
in home rule and this um
piece of legislation goes against that
and we ask you to vote in opposition
i'm sorry i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna ask the uh uh
uh the representatives for additional
questions i think we've gotten
i've been a whole i'm gonna uh ask
unless they are
really pressing questions i will ask the
representatives
to refrain from additional questioning
we have a lot to go through
i want to limit some i'm going to be
limiting
to testimony how many uh
and then we'll uh there's
whoever some additional people who want
to want to talk
uh okay
i mean i'm going to ask
specifically how much time and i'm going
to and if it's
if it goes beyond a certain time that
you give me
i will turn the i will just ask that the
mic be muted
uh
if
uh who do we have next
next i have on the list richard d
pentamina
i'm speaking in opposition my name is
rich deep in tima
i'm the former deputy public health
director for the city of manchester
and a former state representative and
i'm imposed to house bill 6 11 fn
corridation as you know has been in fact
for
voted through a local referendum to add
fluoride to their water systems to
protect the dental health of their
families
these communities did so under the
okay
i asked y'all how long you're going to
be speaking
and you didn't tell me
please tell me how long you're going to
be speaking
mr chairman can you hear me
uh yes could you tell me how long you
plan to be speaking about two minutes
sir oh two minutes all right i will read
i'll read my statement it's very short
right you're on
thank you again i'm rich deep and timo
i'm a former deputy public health
director for the city of manchester and
a former state representative
i'm here to oppose a house bill 611 fn
as i mentioned in these new hampshire
there are a number of municipalities
that have voted through the local
referendum to add florida to their water
systems to protect their dental health
of their families these communities did
so under the provisions of rsa 485-14
this statute also established the
process for any community that wishes to
remove fluoride from their public water
supply
house bill 4 611 is an attempt by a
small group of anti-fluoridation people
to sidestep this process and have the
legislature do for them what they were
unable or unwilling to do on the rsa
485-14 process
they are asking the legislature to
nullify the legal and fair elections and
votes of thousands of people
if there was such a large community
opposition to fluoridation as the
supporters claimed that it should be
very easy for them to have fluoridation
ended to referendum process
the reality is however that support does
not exist so they must use the
legislative process to achieve their
goal
when people voted for fluoridation they
were telling the government of their
community what they wanted
this legislation will negate the wishes
of the people and result in the
government telling these people what
they can or cannot have
this legislation is overreaching and big
government at its worst
it's interesting to note that of the
seven sponsors only one of the sponsors
it represents a community with community
water fluoridation
where are the the representatives of the
communities that have water fluoridation
opposing continuing water fluoridation
the sponsor of this bill has stated that
the votes to approve fluoridation were
won by narrow vote victories and their
voter turnout was small this is not
accurate
in 1999 when manchester voted to approve
fluoridation they also voted for their
mayor during the same election
mayor baines won the election and his
margin of victory was almost identical
to the margin of victory which florida
was approved
should the election of mayor baines be
questioned because of his margin of
victory and the number of voters who
were voted i think not
and when the manchester fluoridation
question was repeated a few years later
adding the other communities served by
the manchester water system the margin
of victory was even greater
house bill 611 fn represents a very bad
public health policy and is contrary to
our basic democratic values
i hope that you don't realize the nature
of this attempt to undo the legal and
safe votes of
thousands of people over the last 50
years in new hampshire thank you very
much and i'll be happy to answer
questions and just let you know mr
representative morin
you asked the question about other
chemicals being added into the water
supply
um unfortunately you can get an answer
but there are a host of other chemicals
that are added to water supplies at the
local level to deal with many many
issues relative to
controlling corrosion uh also
chemicals added for
protecting the minutes are up
okay
next
there are no there'll be no questions
next i have norman ali
a member of the public representing
himself and uh speaking in support of
the bill
mr alley
norman
mr alex raise your hand
all right give me another one
next we have myra
nikitas
member of the public speaking in
opposition to the bill
i like the question
okay all right uh
she's gonna find you
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee um my name is
and i'm here to speak in opposition to
hb 611
are you planning to speak how long do
i'm sorry how long do you plan to speak
oh um maybe about a minute minute and a
half
all right
your start
thank you
i am currently the president of the new
hampshire dental hygienist association
and i'm a practicing dental hygienist at
the greater nashua dental connection
since november of 1998 the mission of
the greater national dental connection
has focused on improved access for
affordable dental care
to individuals and families who qualify
for services to those who are at or
below 200 percent of the national
poverty level
or without dental insurance and live in
new hampshire
the dental connection serves people of
all ages regardless of financial
linguistic cultural geographic barriers
and facilitates
their access to dental services
on a daily basis we are treating
patients as young as one years old who
suffer from dental pain bacteria from
tooth decay can spread from person to
person in a number of ways including but
not limited to sharing food using the
same eating utensils and kissing
just like catching a cold in the winter
time you can also catch a cavity from a
loved one
water fluoridation may be the only
source of preventative dental care for
many low-income patients in new
hampshire
keep in mind that new hampshire medicaid
covers preventative dental treatment
only for patients up to age 21.
rampant tooth decay in children and
adults can be prevented by water
fluoridation
the frequent and consistent contact with
the tooth surface strengthens the tooth
and stops cavities from forming for
younger children fluoride helps
strengthen the permanent teeth still in
development process
for adults fluoride helps support strong
tooth enamel the outer layer of the
tooth keeping teeth strong and healthy
although other products containing
fluoride such as toothpaste mouth rinses
and dietary supplements are available
and contribute to the prevention and
control tooth decay community water
fluoridation is more cost effective and
convenient
in water florida if water fluoridation
is abolished will be creating a
disservice to the community who needs it
most the lack of proper oral health care
coupled with the financial burdens has
kept many in our state without proper
oral health care for many years
fluoridation in the water may be the
only way to break the generational cycle
of tooth decay and poor oral health
i work in this public health i treat
patients day to day rampant decay is a
problem if you abolish
fluoridation and water we will have a
bigger oral health care crisis
i welcome any of the members who are
who
want to abolish fluoridation and water
to come into the clinic and see what i
see on a daily basis
when a child has a toothache as as young
as two years old who's been crying up
all night
this is the only preventative
way that some of these kids are getting
care their parents can't take time off
of work and come and get them treatment
they can't afford to go and buy some of
these toothpaste that are three or four
or five dollars
some of these patients are on a fixed
income
if you take away this water fluoridation
these children have no chance
no chance at all and the numbers will
increase in the emergency room
it will be a big big problem i i see it
my heart breaks every day for a lot of
these kids who have six-year molars
at the age of seven who are already
bombed out and have to be extracted
because parents just can only do so much
they can only buy a certain amount of
things they go to the store or they can
only afford
so many things um and maybe
buying preventative things for to
prevent a cavity for these kids
maybe isn't
isn't what they can afford when they're
thinking about
you know getting heat
thank you i appreciate your time and
thank you for listening to my testimony
i'd be open to any questions at the end
if there if need be thank you very much
representing ourselves speaking in
support of the bill uh
is jennifer padoni
do you want to give her guidance now yes
i know i do
hand up uh
jennifer her mike is now there but it's
muted your mic is muted
jennifer and she's ready
uh jennifer how long do you wish to
speak
she's muted right now she's going back
and forth you're muted
there's nothing we can do
also
okay next we have norman
alley
norman ally
representing himself
uh
in support of the bill all right norman
ali how long do you wish to speak
about three minutes can you hear me
uh yep
i can hear you
left a little bit away
okay
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee
i'm norman ali property owner and former
resident
of dover new hampshire
i moved to dover in 2014
i fully understood that unfortunately
the water was fluoridated and i wanted
to tell you my story
on my efforts to remove fluoride from
the water
well should i say my efforts to
not ingest the fluoride from the water
which began with
a bottled water delivery service which
as you know is fairly expensive but at
the time when i looked at it seemed
fairly reasonable given
the luggage
back and forth is that you know the
other option would be lugging a jug from
the supermarket
so it started out somewhere around i
want to say a dollar thirty a gallon
delivered
but it wasn't long within a few years
before it was approaching two dollars a
gallon
that started to be the breaking point
for me
so i started to look for some other
options
and i had a i had a water system or i
have a cartridge filter system in my
basement already
um so it was ready to try something so
what i did is i tried an activated
aluminum cartridge which was about 200
every six months if it worked but it
didn't work
the the flow rate on the whole house
went down to about zero
so back to the drawing board then i
tried a bone char filter in the
cartridge filter that would be about 130
dollars every three months
well i can't tell you whether or not
that was affected because
it leached into the system and all i
could see was black in my water
so and i tried twice and so that was a i
guess a design failure and i can't
understand how they sell them and i
don't understand it but anyway i moved
on from that
so then i stepped up the stepped up the
prices and stepped up the technology i
went to an under the sink reverse
osmosis system many people think that
gets rid of fluoride
well
four hundred dollars later i don't know
how many hours installing it
and here's the key to the people that
that buy these ro systems that maybe
they don't do
you should check it afterwards i did it
only knocked it down by 50 percent
not good enough ripped it out got my
money back that's the good news at that
point i'm like what do i do now i'm
lugging a jug again i mean i know how
many gal 20 gallons a week because we
cook and drink with it i mean a hassle
expensive so what did i do i pulled out
the big guns i finally gave up i bought
a distiller
and a distiller absolutely takes it out
takes out anything that that that you
know doesn't boil
and
uh that works but twenty five hundred
dollars a hundred dollars a month of
electricity bills to run it
maintenance on top of that
so uh so for for those of us that don't
want this medication which is what it is
uh it's very expensive and it requires a
lot of maintenance and uh
so the comment from miss kramer i
believe it was that said that fluoride
wasn't an additive and not medication
that is absolutely incorrect
and the gentleman spoke a few few
minutes ago chlorine and all those other
things that he was mentioning those are
targeted at the water system they're
additives because they're targeted at
the water system fluoride who is it
targeted it's targeting the user and so
therefore
it is medicine and that's why none of
them will admit it that's why they're
they're trying to they're trying to pull
a fast one on all of you telling you
that it's an additive
chlorine chloramine those other things
corrosion inhibitors those are additives
for the water system not the water using
user so i don't really know how this
antiquated practice that
is still in effect but it is and all i
can say is that i think eventually
it's going to be recognized for what it
is
um and it's going to go the way of
arsenic laced wood
that we found on nearly every children's
playground if you remember about 20
years ago do you all remember that
arsenic laced wooden children's
playground it was on everywhere
overnight it disappeared
i don't know if it'll be an overnight
thing but all i can tell you is that i
think the truth will eventually prevail
right now i urge all of you to support
this bill thank you again one last thing
the comment about big government
big government at its worst
how about forcing someone to take a
medication they don't want i can't think
of any worse example of big government
at its worst thank you very much
thank you very much mr alley
okay mr chair next i have on the list
uh a lobbyist representing new hampshire
dental society
and speaking in opposition to the bill
okay
thank you you can hear me
yep
i will plan to speak uh two to three
minutes max i'm actually timing myself
thank you very much
thank you
uh for the record my name is michael
auerbach i'm the executive director of
the new hampshire dental society on
behalf of our nearly all health 1100
member dentists hygienists assistants
and office staff i offer our vehement
opposition to this dangerous bill
this legislation seeks to without cause
or imperative override municipal
government's decision-making processes
regarding community water fluoridation
more importantly it threatens the public
oral health of new hampshire's residents
especially children
210 million americans currently
including 300 000 new hampshire
residents currently receive the the
health benefits of this practice
according to a wide range of studies as
cited by the american dental association
water fluoridation prevents about 25
percent of tooth decay in both children
and
adults over the last few days you've
received countless studies and documents
from the new hampshire dental society
these are science-based documents to
help you deliberate your vote
proponents of this bill would have you
believe that community water
fluoridation causes amongst other
ailments cancer neurological disorders
birth defects and reductions in iqs
for the record no legitimate study to
date has laid community water
fluoridation as we have described today
to such health and developmental issues
the data provided by the bill's
proponents such as studies in child
development in mexico and canada have
largely been disproven
according to the new according to um
in new hampshire i'm sorry we leave the
decision making right up to the public
as to whether to
engage in cleanly water fluoridation
the proponents of this bill acknowledge
this fact and acknowledge that they seek
passage of this bill because the same
time honored and sound municipal ballot
system has not worked in their favor
residents have by and large chosen not
to revisit the community water
fluoridation programs on the ballot
because they have not experienced any
problems
this bill is a solution to an issue no
one in the affected communities is
experiencing
according to the ada cdc and countless
other organizations both
global and national reference today's
community water fluoridation is the most
cost effective wet method of delivering
the healthy effects of fluoride to all
members of the community regardless of
age educational attainment or income
loan
the past several legislative sessions
this bill was introduced overwhelmingly
and rejected by in bipartisan patch
i ask you as we close i close my
comments who
offer your your comments or your
concerns to your dentist or your
physician and trust them they're there
to help you not to uh to force
medication down your throat we all i i
respectfully requested this committee
reject dangerous legislation like this
and voted inexpedient to legislate thank
you
i will take any questions if you have
any
uh
well i'm not
good well i think we're fine thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
the next one we have on the online list
valerie fraser
yes can you hear me yes how long do you
wish to speak
about two minutes
okay
my name is dr valerie fraser i'm also a
former two-term state representative i
served on a commerce committee and was
the clerk
and i'm here in support of house bill
i do support the idea of abolishing
fluoride in the waters in new hampshire
we've heard a lot of interesting
conversations and interesting testimony
today
um but the bottom line for me and i
think uh it would be
very good to take heart to this is it
doesn't matter how many certificates you
have uh how how what how big an
organization you belong to
none of that matters it is a chemical
that is being introduced into the water
supply
and with the complete inability it is a
drug the fda
is uh designates it as a drug
that you cannot control the dose in the
water and we know that has effects on
infants
they're not supposed to mix their
formula with it and it does have long
lasting health effects
as a veterinarian if a small dog were to
consume a tube of toothpaste he would
die it is a toxin and i remember the
time when children's toothpaste did not
have fluoride in it because it was toxic
and there was fear that because babies
swallow
you know whatever you put in their mouth
they swallow it that they would become
poisoned by it
the other point is that fluoride has an
affinity for the thyroid the breast and
the uterus and those are the three most
common cancers that women get
just about everybody i know as we get
older has osteoarthritis that's also
been linked to fluoride so there are
far-reaching health aspects to it it is
a drug it there's no way to control it
in the water and if a person wants to
in in conjunction with their visit to
their dentist if they want to use
fluoride it can be done easily through
toothpaste fluoride pills
or fluoride treatment on the teeth
but to make the other half of society
that does not want to have medication
forced down their throat as one
gentleman said
uh it would be best to support this bill
and to pass this bill so thank you very
much if you have any questions i'll be
michael all right thank you
thank you very much
uh did i see any uh somebody from the uh
uh the committee raise their hand
and then
if it's you know if it's if it's a
didn't see okay somebody from the
visual committee raised their hand
okay
who do we have next
so so you have uh
representative
and michael are back with a hands up
all right okay well we'll find out uh
representative cushman uh
what uh reason do you like
i'm sorry i didn't i've had my hand up
since
uh before my testimony sorry
oh okay so it's all right okay so you're
not looking at a rebuttal or anything
okay
uh and uh mr arbak had his hand up he's
taking it down okay so he's taking it
down is there anyone else uh in the
audience that has a uh
that has uh a wish too
wish to speak all right
he is taking a stand now he is taking
his hand down all right is there anyone
else if not
i will uh okay so he just
he put his hand back up and you also
have jonathan allen
uh jonathan alley
uh well for
first of all mr lloyd was it
was it
mr
mr mcloyd
do you have your hand up do you wish to
speak
can you hear me now
uh yes how long do you wish to speak yes
thank you mr chairman i wish you speak
for three minutes
uh mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
thomas mcleod i am a resident of mount
vernon new hampshire testifying today as
a member of the public thank you for
hearing my testimony in support of this
bill
members of the committee water
fluoridation however well-intentioned is
in fact a preventative medical treatment
delivered via public water supplies
after all water does not get cavities
people do
there are currently no statutes that
require towns to notify citizens that
the water contains a medical agent nor
any that require towns to explain the
risks and benefits of such therefore
there is effectively no informed consent
to this treatment furthermore delivering
a treatment through the public water
supply is inherently fraught with wet
risks first and foremost there is no way
to control the dosage
after the water leaves the treatment
plant to illustrate one problem assuming
that the concentration of fluoride
leaving the plant is correct and that's
a big assumption assumption
consumers do not necessarily drink water
out of the tap as is
tap water is used for cooking and food
preparation where it may be boiled down
thus increasing the actual concentration
of this medical agent
that the consumer receives on the other
hand people who primarily drink bottled
water receive virtually no flow rate at
all
responding to early testimony that
earlier testimony that
water fluoridation is not a medical
treatment
normally the amount of fluoride in water
is trace
that's naturally occurring fluoride less
than 0.2
or most often less than 0.1 milligrams
per liter the therapeutic dose is now
0.7 milligrams per liter and as they say
the dose makes the medicine
furthermore there is a difference
between the naturally occurring compound
which is usually calcium fluoride and
the water supplement which is generally
phosphate fertilizer scrubber waste
converted to a compound
called
acid
essentially an industrial waste product
uh on a personal note members of the
committee in 2003 my daughter had at age
20 months
fluorosis so severe that several of her
primary teeth had to be removed under
general anesthesia
our dentist confirmed through laboratory
tests that the cause of the destruction
of her teeth was indeed over consumption
of fluoride
at the time we were not notified that
our drinking water contained added
fluoride therefore we took no action to
mitigate the risk
now at age 18 the gap left by my
daughter's previously removed teeth have
left left her with serious orthodontic
problems however the community that
treated her with fluoride without
informed consent now takes no
responsibility for the damage this
treatment caused nor the orthodontic
expenses she faces
members of
the committee the 2005 universal
declaration of bioethics and human
rights ratified by 183 countries
including united states
states any preventative diagnostic or
therapeutic medical intervention is only
to be carried out with the prior free
and informed consent of the person
concerned
my daughter was denied her human right
to inform consent and now suffers the
consequences please support this bill by
[Music]
jonathan alley from nhdes
hello can you hear me
yes how long do you wish to speak i will
try to keep it under two minutes for you
i recognize we're close to five o'clock
okay
you're right hi
hello my name is dr jonathan ali and i'm
the toxicologist of the new hampshire
department of environmental services my
role at des is to evaluate chemicals and
their risk and what they risk those pose
to human health
um i'm not testifying today in support
of opposition of the bill i am just here
today to explain that at des we do
evaluate the risk of chemicals and we
try to do this in a consistent fashion
looking at whatever science is available
in my position i have to evaluate
science that comes from groups that
either are for or against certain
chemicals and i have to look at that as
a whole i also look at international
national studies to do this kind of work
as it relates to fluoride there have
been recent studies that have looked at
potential health effects of fluoride and
this has been a mixed body of literature
um as based on current testimony that
i've heard today it sounds like your
inboxes are going to be inundated with
studies from both sides i will say that
the most recent attempt to coalesce all
this information in a systematic fashion
did conclude that at the levels we
fluoridate drinking water
there is no health risk
so again that is at the levels that we
do fluoridate water they've concluded
that there's not a health risk
the group that did this is with the cdc
it's called the national toxicology
program and this recent work is still
under review because there were
methodological issues with how they
looked at it
the same group was the one that referred
to this as being a developmental
neurotoxin as some of the people
testified today
but again even as our last person who
spoke mentioned it is at higher doses
than what we see with coordination
i recognize that all of you are looking
at a very complicated situation of
judging benefit versus risk and i just
want you to understand that
you have state programs that are here to
help you with understanding that but
also recognize that when toxicology
studies do evaluate the risk of these
chemicals they often exclude analysis of
benefit
so with that i just want to remind you
all that the state resources are here to
help you out if you have questions about
how we evaluate risk how we determine
drinking water levels and what's safe
for everyone in our population from the
elderly to infants our program is here
to support that thank you
okay
uh no position on the bill
uh neither support nor against so
neutral
so position okay
can you hear me
hello
i plan to speak for about three minutes
uh could you make it smaller less we're
almost out of time
absolutely i'll try my best here i'll
get going now
okay my name is lori rosado i'm a
resident in a general dentist serving
the greater concord area i'm here today
in opposition to this bill
in addition to my role as a general
dentist in the area of concord i'm also
actively involved in the concord sealant
coalition which is a non-profit
organization
dedicated to providing care to
underserved children throughout the area
concord's fluoridated water is
definitely helping making a difference
between the young patients that i serve
here in my practice as well as the kids
that the program that i'm a part of
treats in the schools
it's the difference between children
needing a routine cleaning every year
and kids needing extensive and expensive
treatment
um you have to remember not every child
has the opportunity for topical fluoride
whether it's through the toothpaste
through a dental visit
even the programs we do in the schools
they don't all come to see us so this is
why children need that source in
community water
as a dentist in patients of all ages i
can honestly say my over 30 years of
practicing i've not seen the examples of
fluorosis and other conditions that this
bill sponsors claims are happening here
in new hampshire and i've also practiced
in other states have not seen these
severe conditions
you can have fluorosis in teeth when
they quote that 41 percent percent
statistic
you have to realize they're also talking
about one little spot on a tooth i have
one in my own mouth and one of my back
molars i've got a little spot on my
tooth it's been totally fine it doesn't
hurt my mouth at all i can tell you the
majority of the people on this call
probably have those spots somewhere in
their mouth and they would have been
part of that 41
statistic that's quoted
um when they did this in the adolescent
study
so it you know fluorosis is not the be
all end-all of a tooth
and you know they also quoted the
numbers of children
having fluorosis as going up well you
have to realize that you know the
population is increasing
and we're extracting less tea the less
teeth we pull the more teeth we're going
to see that may have a spot on
so you know the science is rather simple
on this and
it just needs to be read thoroughly
and the safety and efficacy of fluoride
is undoubtedly
safe
and very effective
and you could even leave cost out of
this we could say let's not talk about
costs yes it's gonna save you know
medicaid and other organizations
hundreds and hundreds of dollars but
leave cost out of it
it's safe
we should want this for our children and
for everybody i want it for myself
um other things that were mentioned
fluoride as a neurotoxin
in unsafe levels yes
just like everything else it is a
neurotoxin but in the doses that we put
in the community water it is very very
safe there is absolutely no doubt in my
mind how safe fluoride in our community
another mention earlier was um in canada
they are fluoridating the urban areas of
canada i have dental friends that
practice in canada and the community
urban areas of canada are fluoridated
they have the same issues here there are
people there that are against it and
they have you know each municipality
deciding it you know it's it's no
different anywhere else in the world
they know it's safe and the dental
professionals and um you know pediatric
dentists pediatricians in canada
are in
are not in opposition to fluoride they
want the fluoride in the water as well
um you know i want to be here as a
resource for everybody at the end of
today's call and conclusion to this
please feel free to reach out to the
dental society or any of your local
dentists to speak with them because
you know it should be a partnership we
should build this decision together we
should build it mostly in the safe
you know knowing that how safe it is and
and what we can do for our children to
protect them
from having the damage to their teeth
that many of our older population are
suffering from today
that's all i have to say today thank you
thank you you went for four minutes
thank you
thank you very much uh
for the last person on the list
mr johnson presumably hello
yes can you hear me okay
uh yeah if we can hear you fine no how
long do you wish to speak
how about five minutes not trying to get
out of that i'm sorry
sorry no five minutes
four
how about three
you cut me off at three and that'll be
good i'll be fine okay i'm a pediatric
dentist uh
in uh 30 years of practicing
close to
90 hundred thousand patient visits
i have
training and done research and water
fluoridation as well as an infant
formula content of fluorides i stand in
opposition to this bill
which you have heard from those who
oppose water fluoridation
every single point that you have heard
has been scientifically shown to be
inaccurate it is opinion of folks that
believe this sometimes people believe it
because they truly think that it's
causing a health ill and i can be i can
be compassionate with that and
empathetic but science
has to prove things based on the
scientific method and if there is
anything wrong with any part of what we
do whether it's in medicine
dentistry or any other healthcare
profession we are the first ones to step
out against it i just had a hip
replacement two
two weeks ago and god knows there's
enough commercials on tv about did you
get this commerci hip replacement well
you could be suing you know what
we want to know what's wrong so we look
at the research the
systematic research has been done
look at when fluoride was discovered
have the benefits to the cheek it was
we had fluoride discovered as a
positive impact on the health of teeth
it wasn't in 1945
we had no idea what was causing cavity
reductions in these areas where people
had a little brown stain on their teeth
that's called the virginal fluorescent
then we had areas where people in the
areas
that had good looking teeth with little
tiny white marks on their teeth well in
1930 a fluoride probe was invented that
we said let's go back and measure these
areas well in areas like colorado
springs where they had brown stains on
the tee they had two to 12 parts per
million of fluoride in the water health
was great no health issues at all in
areas where it was good
looking teeth and almost no cavities was
one part per million so that's where the
one part per million became set that's
where we added fluoride to the already
existing florida and water in 1945 and a
eight city study that was done and we
found cavity rays to drop off 60 to 70
percent we knew we were onto something
so we replicated what mother nature
showed us fluorides the 13th most
abundant men are on the earth's surface
moving beyond that
all of the studies all the information
you've heard today every bit of it i
would be willing to go through with you
with chapter and verse in scientific
references not to some website not just
something obscure but with every single
thing
noted that you've asked for including
where your additives come from and where
do you purchase them from all of these
things can be answered very simply using
the cdc's website
state information all of it can be
the second thing i want to really
mention to you is the change in the
fluoride level from 0.7 to 1.2 parts per
million
well
thank you very much there is
no more
uh
no more hands up
and
i've already called for that and
that's i will declare is
give me the list
yeah there are i can lead it off too
okay we have
40 on the list in support
of hb611
we have 21 opposed
on the list okay so it's quite expensive
i think all right so so 40 were
so for how 40 were four support
21 opposed
even though there was a large larger
number speaking
in opposition
but they signed in
moore signed in opposed thank you very
much
uh just
going down the list
i do see
some i do see a number of uh
that thank you very much
i've got vote uh first i'm gonna call
this meeting to close
and i'd like to thank the committee for
a long day
it has been a long day
the uh
and i thank you for your forbearance and
uh
i'll see you next uh
next wednesday
bye
yep
shalom